foreign
hello hello it is Wednesday man it is
Wednesday
it is Wednesday it's today's Wednesday
AF
Ghan
March 8th welcome everybody we've got a
great and fantastic show here for a
change for you guys uh
this is going to be one of the good ones
[Music]
foreign
hello
[Music]
that guy is such a character
thank you guys well done by the way is
he still up to the old boys are you
still doing that oh we should check in
and find out because he got roasted
pretty hard I I figured maybe he moved
on past them right also I just realized
so this maybe is a good segue into uh
talking about our new setup but because
of the delay when I hit live
it's on a 20 second delay so we were
sitting there in silence for 20 seconds
they saw episode yeah I didn't say
anything racist did I no that might I
don't think so the mics were down too it
was just like they were just staring at
us oh wait let me go back to the live
and see so from now on I'm gonna have to
oh that's tricky actually I'm gonna have
to hit start like 20 seconds into the
show so here we are
wow wait can you guys hear can they hear
me what I'm saying
what
I wasn't sure if I heard myself saying
something I don't think so yeah okay so
we have a new meta here because of the
buttons to to work out
but um
okay fantastic well we got the buttons
most importantly it's working folks it's
working folks it is working
by the way this shirt is from the new
Teddy fresh collection coming out this
Thursday I feel like it's really
flattering
makes me my I love this shirt it's like
really fits me good I feel like maybe
you're rocking something right yes sir
show it off
okay
oh oh dude that's sick we'll send you
one thank you yeah there's a lot of nice
really nice stuff coming out this
Thursday at uh 10 A.M
I guess we'll have more to show on
Friday but here's the post about it this
one uh Amy's wearing
oh dude the accessories are fire that's
a bag we worked on that's a sweater
graphic
earrings
you like those yeah I'll get you a pair
or just tell Lena backpack
another sweater so nice
that is a collared shirt I believe
and I love this actually this trinket is
so cool
so there's all kinds of fun stuff coming
out on Thursday at 10 A.M at
teddyfresh.com
you know there's a funny post on the
subreddit I wasn't sure they're probably
kidding but it was like what's with H3
and Teddy fresh like why are they their
only sponsor
and all the comments were joking were
jokes but
let me see if I can pull it up I felt
like it must be a joke right you guys
know because he's having a big joke
what's H3 yeah thank you Carlos
um what's h3's relation to Teddy fresh
they asked
just find it odd that Teddy fresh seems
to be the only sponsored I've never
dropped the podcast that's got to be a
joke
um not yet Eli's about to distance
herself for me yeah man am I you know
the button's gonna prevent that the
button is going to save us all you guys
we have sponsors lining up
they heard the button the holy button
careful Careful
by the blood of the Lamb button
he says it's the only podcast they
advertise on plus Ethan and the crew
push it religiously when was the last
time you've seen him wearing any other
brand just a couple of things I've
noticed I figure I should discuss with
the broader Community that's a joke
right they got me trouble yeah it's got
to be
[Music]
top comment I hear Ethan is sleeping
with the owner
scandalous that is scandalous
um
keep me out of it I don't know nothing
about nobody yeah so that's funny
uh by the way a little show note
um
we have no show on Monday and I'll tell
you why
because IL is about to get Prego
magnifico
magnifico The Original Latin for it
and uh our opportunity to take a
romantic
couples Escape
will be closed the short window that we
have is will be closed
and so
we are going for a nice little Retreat
on the weekend and we're driving back on
Monday so there'll be no show on Monday
but I appreciate y'all's support and
then I had a hard time the rest of the
weekend I know I'm sorry I'm sorry it's
just it'll be just this one time and
then I'm here for nine months
Lieutenant ducky says just realize that
the button is going to affect the bingo
game what are we going to do well button
should have been on your bingo card
it is actually on one of them so there
you go button button
uh Mary Jane said it's my husband's
birthday
Happy Birthday Jay peace and love so
here's the button
now how this button Works my friends
thank you Lena
you've got a video
and you've got an audio we are hitting
both oh yeah oh yeah no risks
now this is fully customizable so what
we customized it to is when we slam
these deer buttons it dumps 20 seconds
I did clog the toilet again this morning
right yeah that is true third time in a
week I don't know why I I'm just a
normal guy taking normal poop I don't
believe that I just look at it I'm not
like it's got to be that you're slamming
Metamucil it's not here
so something is wrong something is wrong
Ian made a good point there's seven of
us here
what could be wrong with your poop that
is clogging toilets I wonder if that's
like a clinical diagnosis talking
clogging toys unless there's another the
other variables are you putting are you
putting something else in the toilet yes
I'm flushing toys down the toilet like
my three-year-olds or perhaps toilet
paper Maybe
toilet paper yeah too much toilet paper
too much no see it it I'll tell you I'll
tell you I don't want to get graphic but
it quads before the toilet paper has a
chance too okay I see but the fact that
you went to like always pork it's
brother how the fact that you went to
Toys first scares me a little bit
brother how big are your [__] Theodore
clogged already once oh okay Theodore
um flushed
like the top of a cup down the toilet
and it got clogged and I was like did
you put it did you flush something he's
like no I was like okay it was so
clogged plumbers had to come unscrew the
toilet
and fish out and sure enough here comes
the top of his cup and I'm like
you know he he doesn't chip off the old
block liar dude he doesn't care how how
big are your dumps dude
I mean look at me I'm just a normal dump
like I take [__] you know dinosaur
shits but like you must be taking like
woolly mammoth like great [__] like
dinosaurs bigger than woolly mammoth
well okay
you want to rethink that analogy I'll
rewind it maybe here's the button hit
the button maybe you're the woolly
mammoth Zach and he's the taking the
deck I don't know what to tell you okay
if there's any doctors that want to
diagnose me with like colon cancer
because my shits are huge go ahead is it
wet are you firm no it's wet it's wet
and soft
just like I like my protection
Jesus on International women's day Ethan
literally come on dude what's better
than that I like my women like I like my
shits wet and soft
um anyway you are I said dumping on a
tangent uh-huh so we push the button
20 seconds retroactively so from the
moment the button is pressed we re it's
rewind time uh
and uh yeah the stream itself is on a 30
second delay so so right now guys I'm
going to show you with peace and love a
demonstration of the power of the button
this twenty thousand dollar Gadget which
Dan thank you Dan and good work put in a
lot of effort to technically set this
thing up this is a very I can't
emphasize that how much of a serious
piece of Hardware this is
right Dan
uh yeah I mean it's it's high-end
broadcast gear so it was a little touchy
setting up but we got it we got it
working that was some serious [__] yeah
and Riley says first time I've been able
to watch in a while thank you God bless
glad you're here
Violet says Blame It On Teddy listen
it is what it is
um a gift from God wow this is what it's
gonna be like we're never gonna get in
trouble again
this is what oh should we button this
this could be insensitive to the
Christians
[Music]
Church of the button
the Church of the button
sit in reverence
the button erases all past
tribulations the memory hole
you can now go back in time we've often
wished
when we made blunders or embarrassments
to just go back in time and change it
now we have the power
again
all right so here's what I'm going to do
to demonstrate the power I'm going to
count to 30.
and then hypothetically if I hit it on
10 they'll see me count to 10 and then I
will dump no if you hit it on 30 they'll
see you count to ten okay okay right so
I'm gonna count to 30 and then I'm gonna
dump it and then it'll stop at 10.
uh right they'll see you count up to 10
and then it'll cut to the screen for 20
seconds 20 seconds it's gonna kill it
and it's going to put like uh air button
time okay so it's gonna be 20 seconds of
dead air okay guys
so work with so no different than a
normal episode yeah thank you Dan
all right here we go
should we count together so after 10 I'm
gonna be saying a ton of racial slurs
and super racist jokes and homophobic
stuff as well
not really he's not actually going to do
it well they won't know
[Music]
release
you were supposed to hit it on 30.
they'll be seeing this let's see what
happens oh they see this well now that
you released it yeah but us is going to
go back yes let's see what it looks like
all right we'll try it again we'll try
it again we'll try it again
you know we we're working through this
we're working through it
so they're not going to see my countdown
no because you yeah so wait wait
okay okay they're they're currently I I
can see it because I'm watching this
yeah they're they're currently there it
goes there it goes
so let's see what you guys think about
that yeah I kind of played that wrong
but this is why we're working it out
we're working the ginks out
all different flavors all the different
flavors so I'll do it again as they wait
I can do it again right
yeah yeah I mean if you want yeah sure
so count to 30 to 30 and I would hit it
at like here I'll do you a favor I'll do
your favor right now hold on we'll make
it a lot easier
because your counting isn't super
accurate so here's a stopwatch
when do I tell my most racist joke
around 20 seconds around 15 seconds yeah
anything after 10 it will theoretically
but don't don't actually do that just to
be clear just in case well I will but
they won't know the difference
word that's one of the words that I'll
be featuring during the 15th even joke
son of a [__] what the n-word is uh you
know what the N word is yeah
all right so I'm going to start the
stopwatch on screen you see this okay go
ahead all right so here we go we're
featuring The seconds are ticking lots
of excitement
we're coming up on the racist Olympics
here
[Music]
foreign
what the [__] dude hey I hope that
didn't go out I hope that didn't go out
it didn't I hit the button yikes but you
know what you left Dan you left no I
don't even say that you laughed bro no
you thought it was funny you can't talk
[__] it's funny sorry
all right I'm watching it back to see so
let's see
people go why racist well what a mouse
am I supposed to say that's uh dicey
dicey
I guess I could have done a death threat
racist next time I'll do a death threat
you're right
that would be
on brand yeah it goes with the trend
yeah
okay so so tell me how did that one go
off I see the standby it's on the
standby right now did you see where it
got cut off at a good spot were you
hearing the Audio I wasn't able to
switch over quick enough so people are
saying it works yeah
I heard not yeah I saw when I came back
it looked like it was me yelling at you
yes you guys we got the button back
so this is it
you know I feel like we've really
ascended it works this is literally
1984. we're deleting history that's it
[__] it Whatever It Takes Man Delete
delete
you said it was around nine okay around
nine seconds it disappeared
that's when I wish death upon all my
enemies in specific details and
locations and times
no we were counting calmly
and um
and you guys didn't see that part
[Music]
that's awesome dude I love this thing
dude I love it
so you know like
I appreciate that you know I'm I'm a
little too uh unpredictable for some
Brands and stuff and I think this really
and just for our own state of of mine
because
I don't enjoy getting kicked off for a
week either that's a [__] problem
I love this button and so I love this I
think this is fantastic good job Dan and
I think this was money well spent
oh if it yeah if it were if it if it
works even once it will likely have paid
for himself oh it will so big
differences there you go how you pay I
have a I have a feeling we'll probably
be using it in Earnest this episode
um so you can retire better let's try
not to you see this Benadryl
oh you're on Benadryl okay yeah let's
have it ready can you see I don't it's
not showing up good on the camera
okay so when I did the fika fish last
time I got this really horrible rash
around my eyes under my eyebrows and
last night
I started getting the same rash
under my eyes it's super red and puffy
and
itchy and painful
I have not taken a Benadryl yet now
here's here's
red right Zach you're on another [__]
planet bro
I'm gonna take my banjo and then I'm
gonna tell you guys what happened
you're gonna get real loopy off that
Benny
everyone's asking if Josh said this was
okay I'll explain that too it's somewhat
related to the story I'm about to tell
thank you mirror
sedge girl
so they get did they get
so yesterday on our members alive
we're watching Eddie burback's new video
about ghost kitchens good guy great guy
check it out and he has a section about
Mr Beast ghost kitchen
and like our experience his was not good
and if you guys remember the last time I
got
Beast it was the worst Food I've ever
ordered and I'm not saying that to be
hyperbolic or to be con to be a dick it
was genuinely
it was genuinely [__] crazyly bad
did I not say Beast burger what did I
say did I not say it yeah so Peace
Burger obviously
and so everybody was encouraging me to
order it
to Vibe check it again
and I did order it
and surprisingly it turned out good it
turned out it showed up in the boxes the
food looked like it was shown and I mean
listen I wouldn't go and order it
but I wouldn't be disappointed if I
ordered that either so that's like the
best experience I've had
with with Beast Burger now that
is pretty much the only thing I ate
was it people are saying it was the Bel
Air Beast Burger
I think it did come from
it came from Brentwood so it probably
was
something that's not like super low
end but who knows
but it looked good
so I didn't need anything else in that
day because I ate a lot of calories I
was feeling really bad about myself the
whole [__] day I knew that if I
ordered it I was going to eat too much
of it I didn't want to do it but you
guys made me do it
did I take the Benadryl already yes
another one one missing no do not so we
know for sure
and now in the evening my [__] eyes
start to Brash the only ever time I've
had this rash is twice when we had FICA
fish because there's some [__] insane
preservative psycho chemical going on in
that now I want to know what the [__] is
in that Beast Burger
so that one time I had a good experience
my my eyes are popping out of my [__]
head with some crazy ass rash Jimmy
sends his records
I guess so I heard I heard even
I heard you've been saying something I
already been saying some things about me
then
some things that uh not that nice
now
I run this town YouTube it's my place I
can't allow people to run around saying
bad things about me it hurts my
reputation it makes me
makes me look kind of bad
it was sixty dollars too I mean you know
it's you can only order it via delivery
service and you know how it goes with
that it's expensive sure wait it was
sixty dollars for one burger no no no no
I got like the burger I got French fries
I got a grilled cheese and a chicken
sandwich oh okay but still that seems
like a lot
yeah I mean the total was like 35 and
then you know the fees and [__] oh God
yes
so I don't know what the [__] happened
but
um
I'm in a rotten fish I don't know that
you guys are here first I guess it
doesn't really show up but it looks like
I have Uncle Fester makeup on
just a little bit huge bags bruh
and so anyway who is Josh people are
asking who's Josh
that was another meme from the member
stream where
this dude named Joshua I don't remember
I'm not trying to put on blast let's
just call him Joshua I was watching
Eddie's video and he goes in all caps oh
God I can't I'm so glad I paid for this
membership to watch you watch other
people's content and I said Joshua I'm
so I I just I know
he's right he's just he's right and now
I have to go to Joshua before I get
approved before he needs to approve
everything I do he's he's kind of the
executive Joshua please tell me what to
watch I just want I just want to
entertain you and you alone this is your
show this is your time Joshua I put my
hands up like this just because like I'm
bleeding not to be graphic but you know
what I mean like I'm just I'm I'm
pleading and I'm pleading and I'm
bleeding Joshua please
so that's who Joshua is he's probably
going to become like a meme now
don't be a Joshua
do we know any joshuas I don't want to
denigrate the whole name of Joshua
Josh I've known Josh's throughout my
life I'm not you know actively in
contact with any Josh's so I think it's
okay to dunk on that name people are
saying it's important for me to mention
that I did leave a 20 tip in part of
that sixty dollars so
wow we know uh mythical Chef Josh oh
mythical Chef Josh great guy I don't
want him catching Strays yeah yeah yeah
sometimes war war never changes
anyway today's is international women's
day yeah
give it up give it up
shout out to all of our ladies this is
uh I guess on the uh we are honoring the
ladies of H3
no we don't play that today Zach not
today Zach not today Zach man happy
International women's day to the ladies
I don't know what it means but it's
today we celebrate you guys so be honest
the guys and the beautiful women and
them
would you would the ladies like to uh
say anything on beach yeah
thanks guys thank you well thank you
thank you guys and to all the women of
the world you are beautiful amazing you
are
welcome
be you you are strong you are so smart
empowered and you're hot yes yes
empowering yeah
yeah I feel powerful for the ladies
where's Sam I just saw you can cut to
Sam
Sam any words of empowerment she's
downstairs steady fresh shoes
she's such a boss uh girl that she's
downstairs doing other things
damn it's just a real talent thank you
Jordan we didn't let the girls work
today Olivia was trying to do some labor
we didn't let it do it today we said
Olivia put that down
she tried to pick she tried to pick up a
cup to to bring me water it's true I was
gonna vacuum maybe he said nope I
slapped it out of her hand for real he
literally literally hit me and said give
me the vacuum kidding kidding kidding
exactly but I did a women's day women's
day I did take the vacuum though yes
that was very good that's true story
she's letting them all know
I saw Olivia typing up research I shoved
her as hard as I could
she fell over violently I said what
today woman's wept her leg not today
like at Mortal Kombat yeah
Hello Olivia yeah she tried to do the
dishes I said it's okay leave them till
tomorrow he could do them ah good one
there it is
um
today we are
doing a huge analysis as you guys know
we've enjoyed putting Subway Surfer
hydraulic press soap cutting
kinetic sand next to videos this is a
phenomenon
and I asked love Let's do an analysis
the Subway Surfer one
with the normal one back to back
yep and let's find out let's get to the
bombas does this
help does it help and so we have a whole
analysis ready for you guys we'll be
getting into that later
very excited
uh that's kind of our then we got the
Elon Musk then we've got the Nick Cannon
this man Nick Cannon is a [__] demon
dude
so gross I don't get into it right now
but I'll just show you you guys probably
all heard about this [__]
who's having my baby like what are you
this is not a joke bro
who wants to have who wants to be who
wants to have an absentee father like
what do you what is this show so who
wants to have a bat my bastard child
so is there is there any uh doubt that
this is real because it just seems so
unbelievable like when we all saw it
yesterday a lot of us were thinking it
was a joke or something it's on E which
is which you know the only other channel
would be more on brand four is The
Learning Channel but east right there
um I think it's real there's a preview
there's a trailer hey I think it's real
wait a minute I think I think it may
have been debunked
oh
I'm seeing an article from three hours
ago on today
yep yep they got us it's a hoax so wait
why so what's the I was wondering that
yesterday I was like is it a uh is it a
early April Fool's joke or something
should have waited wait why did they do
this it's bizarre it's not funny anymore
all right let's just talk about it I
always do this let's just get into it
because we're here here's the trailer
guys but the fact that you can even make
this joke kind of says it all bro right
yeah no it's still like dude very weird
you got too many kids it's not even
really fun oh okay did you want to know
the answer yeah
it is actually part of an upcoming
celebrity prank show I knew it we're
back I knew it punked is back baby well
it's not actually punked but that kind
of nonsense Closer by Kevin Hart
yeah I assume so if he's involved hosted
by comedian well right the fake one is
hosted by him
oh I guess the the
reply kind of says it we're definitely
not kidding around so excited for this
prank bro well because that was that was
the tagline in the in the trailer for
the fake show okay well here let's watch
the trailer uh you know it's not real
but still shame on them guys
I found a game show right now
game show
[Music]
[Applause]
that want to have your face are they
pranking him
this
is
hell today we're going to it's probably
Kevin Hart pranking Nick Cannon like
brought him on and he didn't know okay
he's gonna be called that or whatever
okay that's my guess okay if it was like
VH1 I would have believed it I would
have been more like it was TLC I would
have been or TLC yeah but VH1 had like
Flavor of Love you think he's too classy
for this yeah
I mean he does I mean they have reality
shows but it's like the Kardashians and
stuff it's not like as
well I guess depending on who you asked
the strategy too but I don't know thank
you Lauren Courtney for the five gifted
subbies and we love you for that all
right well I guess we got God
but still shame on you Nick Cannon stop
having kids
stop it
those kids need their two parents stop
it you got ten different baby mamas
don't you tell me your presence in their
life
imagine what those cookouts look like
dude when they have a barbecue it's like
um
it's like a goddamn
like a goddamn uh looks like a fire
drill you know what I mean at the like
an elementary score everyone comes
pouring out of school there's like
thousands of kids
they're lining up on the yeah on the
baseball diamond yep so up there Nick
goes down and just hi I'm hi I'm Nick he
introduced himself to all of his kids
nice to see you
it's embarrassing stop it
stop it you're not Genghis Khan bro
you're just like a TV host it's not that
serious you don't need a thousand kids
so there's that okay I guess not that
big of a deal
thank you thank you should I just button
this whole segment
it's too late now it was longer than 20
seconds look if I just hold it down
because it looks like they only cop to
it a few hours before we went live so uh
yeah no we're doing a service it's like
with the taste story all the news
outlets are still talking about it being
real so we're right on the um right
we're right on the cusp of cutting
bleeding edge news that's right Gotti
that's right
so okay let's move on top of the show
stuff Eddie good friend of the show we
love Eddie shirtlessetti uh who was here
on Monday we had so much fun with him he
was trying to get to a hundred thousand
he's getting he was at 70. so he's he's
almost gained 20 000 since Monday that's
great
he's actually gotten into he's getting a
little bit of heat because of the one
he shot with the kids did you know about
this Dan
uh uh well I remember did he shoot it
while we were live yes and I was like
yeah no no no don't show the kids don't
show the kids
it's further down Ethan he uploads dude
what the [__] he's uploaded all these
dude he just he doesn't review him he
just runs and guns dude he just hits
post I like that's such a nice mentality
they're just like you don't get married
to the content you don't get attached
you film it you put it out I love that I
sent it if you want I'm just kind of
interested at how much he's posting you
could see everywhere he goes in town
yeah he could follow his whole day
that was on a set
I kind of want to see this one make a
name for yourself on Tick Tock it often
helps to have some sort of give that
Best Buy
oh he's doing it okay
found his successful formula Eddie
lavesi AKA shirtless Eddie oh it's from
Know Your Meme oh okay okay Eddie
so this is all what we did yesterday
some of these actually did quite well
this one got a oh yeah this the one that
went viral I'm gonna click it he already
put it out there so I'm gonna click it
it's a little too late yeah I was
filming the quick roads box at this time
yeah but uh I think it's worth seeing it
is pretty interesting
hey Eddie what are you doing in the
Walmart with your shirt off
yeah I mean those kids don't exactly
look like
comfortable the mom is kind of
protecting them yeah there's some fear
potentially in their face and
you're pushed into the cereal aisle well
you were there cam what was your
impression of the exchange uh uh
honestly I was so over stimulated with
that whole day I wasn't thinking about
anything
um I was just I didn't want to film the
kids so I was filming the close-up of
the Quaker Oats at the time right and um
I actually recorded the um any part
because I just I said I'll record it
don't worry I'll record this part oh
good call Cam yeah so good morning when
you see the screen recording him on on
the show that was me you left it you let
the terrified family walk through yeah
I do want to emphasize like
Eddie's like the nicest most
unthreatening Guy and um
I don't I think he just needs I think we
need to rule just not to film kids yeah
just like let's just set you know that's
my advice to you Eddie yeah that's good
advice in the comments
are uh
you know a little critical
but we love Eddie and uh he's learning
yeah I mean it's it's fine nobody's hurt
no he's all good you know moving forward
maybe no more kids this is what it what
it means everything gets scrutinized
Eddie we're on the road to fame and
we're we're improving every day right
you should check out the one with the
guy in the red shirt if you recall that
took like 20 takes for him to record
this one did pretty good 150 000 views
yep say hey Eddie what are you doing
you're in the Walmart with your shirt
off put your shirt back on okay ready
all right lovey films all day what are
you doing in the whole
lost a lot of weight
you're sure
hold on
Cameron say hey everyone that's it
you're in the Walmart with your shirt
off oh that's the whole video that's it
remember how long like they were taking
to try and record like 15 takes because
he couldn't figure out how to record his
record button's a little bit busted so
this happened a lot where nobody could
really hit record on it and then it made
for little mistakes that were beautiful
like that yeah but Eddie's doing great
and uh we'll just tell him no kids if we
can potentially pass that on to him yeah
yeah I don't want him to notice yeah
exactly yeah yeah so there it is Eddie
I still don't understand love lovesy
lovese Eddie Levesque a little uh a
little behind the scenes too when we
were in the Walmart parking lot he's
such a busy guy he uh he replied to two
extra acting gigs too when we're in the
park of course wow yeah he's always on
that ground he's on yeah I respect the
Hustle Man
he's shirtless he's this he's that he's
in the Walmart he's he's answering
uh acting gigs
that man was running around Walmart
shirtless for like an hour
I can't believe we didn't get kicked out
dude he went up to an employee at the
entrance and she gave him instructions
wasn't it straight was it a manager even
I don't know I'm not sure I know
normally it's playground most of them
were the mindset that we weren't
hurting anybody I don't think
um and they just didn't want to deal
with it yeah no they don't get paid
enough to deal with that I I didn't get
it but the first one there was like 10
Walmart people surrounding us telling us
to leave yeah I remember that one yeah I
think it's just a matter of if the
manager gives the call right
you know because if I'm working there
I'm not [__] I don't I'm not dealing
with that [__] no
hell no
we are we are Walmart
thank you
yeah exciting this Saturday we're
putting up our first lore video on the
main Channel
shout out to the family
very excited for that series to begin
it's gonna be great shout out to his
family
so oh this is an old one eh so I'm not
even gonna show this one I thought it
was new this poll
is there a new one that we can reference
uh they update those every six months or
so
[Music]
um
so maybe I mean on this list the only
YouTube podcast ahead of us is impulsive
but that can't be right
I can't be right
[Applause]
that can't be right dude this number
seven is Ben Shapiro y'all we are so
[__] we are so [__]
that this Gremlin is talking into the
ears of America
I'm inside your walls Ben this man is
Whispering into your ears to like
Round Up trans people
because he's too fragile
uh
uh let me look at impulsive are his
views dropped off since people since um
I think I might have just found the most
recent one yeah because everyone got mad
at him recently for the the scams
I just said one in Discord oh and we've
Fallen even further it's actually even
worse than we thought don't say that
it's true this man does it once a week
it's like they're not that impressive
the numbers hold the [__] phone
hold the [__] phone let me pull this
up see this okay this is not good let me
see this is not good hold on hold on
hold on let me go
that's it
just click it oh [__] this is not good
38 [__] 38 dude at least we're ahead
of crowder [__] oh get [__] Crowder
did they account for YouTube views
that's what I'm wondering uh so from
what I remember this one is it's not
it's like a survey and uh surveying 10
597 podcast consumers ages 13 older
participants indicate which podcast
they've listened to in the past week
along with a variety of demographics
psychographic and purchase Behavior
information this is Q3
uh I feel like we'll perform better
through four
I think we're gonna do better this on
the first queue I feel like we've been
doing strong numbers and people like
compulsive are people hate and Paul so
finally let's get that off the list and
then let's see here
um
yeah like I I don't know I'm just happy
to be on the list I'm not because it's
not enough for me but we spend so much
time we're here at [__] five days a
week we do grind nobody nobody does what
we do nobody I do yeah we're about
Crowder we're above full send or above
no jumper we're above Lex Friedman that
loser idiot dumbass
um oh I'm so smart MIT shut up so you
know right is Shady on there
is he not even on here he's a [__]
loser he paid off the what what is it
what's uh
what's his uh on brand with Jay Shetty
or like what the [__] is his podcast
called I don't see Shetty
he's not even on this list absolute
loser idiot Chomp Chomp [__] but what I
don't get is like impulsive is really 15
like I'm sorry I just don't buy that
that's just [__] nobody's listening
impulsive well it's just one survey it's
10 a little over ten thousand people
that are being asked so you know
oh that's okay well I'm feeling cue I
feel like the Q one and two of this year
we're gonna move up I feel it I feel it
I feel it okay guys if you get a call is
it possible that people are embarrassed
to admit they listen to this podcast
they're like [__] I don't know and they
just go uh Joe Rogan
they go oh impulsive
that's funny
thank you
and that's why we should be number one
because I'm funny
it's funny but I hope with the lore
series we may be able to initiate some
new members you know that's the goal
that's that's what we're trying to do
here
so okay we're on the list but
oh we got analytics okay okay okay
let's pull this up
let's see so here's impulsive
who is a [__] giant this show sucks
it's peaked and it's fallen off
okay I wrestle the bear
he's getting about 10 million per month
now let's pull up ours remember we were
gone for all of
we had a fat vacation
oh God okay we're on an upswing we're on
an upswing but also our increments are
bigger it's 24 yeah 20 million
yeah 20 million the first line is 20
million for us so yeah we're actually
significantly higher wait this was
Frenemies that was oh yeah 21 yeah
dude the friendly [__] was just but
again the survey isn't a matter of how
many views it's yeah yeah how many
listeners total listeners right
God Friendly's was nuts man we were
doing like 50 million that's insane for
a podcast that's crazy what the [__] but
we're popping up we're popping up I like
that you know
so let's get it let's get this get it
let's get this [__] do it and top of the
morning hold on let's get this [__]
[__] you Logan Paul
whoa that was kind of hype
that was pretty hype so thank you but
thank you everyone who listens it's
pretty it is pretty epic that we're even
on the list I I'll get because you know
we're amongst like world famous
comedians and [__]
and world famous exactly when I see that
when I see us on the same list as like
Conan O'Brien who like is a comedy
legend that I've watched since I was a
kid Conan O'Brien is our competition
it's pretty wild Conan O'Brien is my
contemporary he's my equal
yeah you're around the same age
um well that's not true you just said
contemporary no well yeah that doesn't
mean same age yeah let's be real though
this Show's a lot more entertaining than
what it shows what is 59 this man is old
as [__]
Ethan didn't know your birthday was
International women's day no wonder
you're such an ally to win literally
[Music]
we're not the same age Ethan climbed the
OG woman even if I'm 42 which I'm not
he's significantly older than you
wow that took a lifetime of difference
now we're gonna make today special for
you it's your birthday
happy birthday dude put that [__]
thing away who gave me that mocha you
know call it cream yeah they're all
different flavors
we got another all different flavors
sound bite from Jimmy
it's awesome
I guess for a month waiting to use it
waiting for that his wife
oh interesting she's very pretty
who is she why are you worried about my
wife shut up who is she
well I wonder if she's like a
a writer or a producer
her name is I think
copywriter oh yeah see I knew it it's
always like that
Lisa she spells Lisa with a z
Lisa Liza Eliza
Liza Powell O'Brien
Lisa
uh we honor her on women's day this is
international women's day and we honor
Lisa
who's a copywriter of great of Fame
great Fame
fantastic
worser Wikipedia page
oh she doesn't have one
okay
I'm kind of misogynist and embarrassing
didn't have a Wikipedia page okay
Boop
anyway moving on
thank you Ashley 30th birthday today
she lost 100 pounds almost in a year
actually her birthday
whoa good for you nice
love that for you
um there's a really good Andrew Tate
revelation
I mean it's fun to see because he's part
of the ultra conservative reactionary
alpha males and there's a video that
surfaced from
2021 July
of him doing this kind of bit that I see
a lot of conservatives do I've seen
I saw Joe Rogan do it recently where he
the the stick is like oh well trans
women they have a dick so it's less gay
and they're just worried about they're
like if I'm watching porn I need to be
the least gay Possible porn
but so in their mathematics they think
that
would you trans I think you said that
the transporn is less gay in their
opinion because the
the person with the penis also has boobs
oh I see what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah right so they've crunched the
numbers on that right so instead of like
they're doing they're doing the Calculus
if you look at a woman a traditional CIS
woman
she's got boobs and a vagina so she's a
hundred percent not gay
of Rogan okay yeah and so if you look at
a trans woman she has boobs so that's
not gay right and she but she but she
has a penis which is gay right so
instead of 50 gay watching transporn is
only is actually 75 straight straight
and 25 gay I understand okay so that's
what Joe Rogan and so so so in their
view just
traditional heterosexual porn with them
with a CIS man and woman having sex
that's 50 gay it's gay yes 50 gay it's
50 and then and they they're ashamed to
watch that okay it's 50 50. there you go
so here is
and you take oh you should give a
trigger warning too by the way what is
he oh he says the T he's there's some
slurs in this he it's it's such a
bizarre clip because he's like kind of
he's kind of supporting oh he's
transcribes but like in the in the most
misogynistic insane way possible wall so
dropping slurs left and right yes but it
is interesting
um
it's gives Chaser energy and uh that's
what everybody's saying it's it's so it
is very interesting it's like
there is a phenomenon of these Ultra
masculine
Alpha Sigma whatever they see themselves
and these are the guys who spent all day
in the gym they are admiring each other
physique they're getting jacked for each
other we've established that women
aren't really attracted to like big old
muscle dudes that's like a guy thing
Bugatti
and so I do think like deep down a lot
of these guys do want to [__] dudes
they're bisexual they're bicurious yeah
which is natural right it's just less
acceptable for men to express that yeah
curiosity which he does say in this
video as well he does say that so
surprisingly vulnerable gender is a
spectrum in fluid he says it all
so it's like he's saying some good stuff
and intermingling it with slurs and um
well you'll see I mean there's one part
in particular that really gets me about
it so we're gonna we're gonna analyze
this and it's very interesting it is
very interesting but if you're if you're
sensitive to a
a slur for Trans people you guys know
the word I'm referring to he does say it
so heads up on that one
here it is Andrew Tate ignore the
construction I'm rebuilding my Mansion
you'll see when it shut up
don't hear any construction
your Mansion sucks by the way if you
have to rebuild it [__] sucks he said
nothing and it was too much yeah stop
two words
start we'll do an episode of cribs I had
to I had to hit this area here I bought
my neighbor's house
dropped a specific area for the Bugatti
turn it up a little bit anyway the
Bugatti
dude why button it at all at that point
I mean
the man buttoned it like a suit like a
suit jacket right it's that's not a suit
jacket dude it's right [__] shirt I
mean you're Zach you're way more button
up than him
he's got one button like on the belly
button right oh geez
[Laughter]
all right
anyway that's all gonna be lit up and
[__] you got you logos people broke Boys
Don't Know listen Gotti I recently
posted a question on Twitter
asking
would you rather have sex with a
transsexual which is a legitimate 10 or
a woman which is a legitimate one
Okay so
so he is admitting in a sense that
he's already admitting too much that it
for him's comfort
he doesn't realize he's saying I there's
transsexual women who are a 10. right
yeah yeah which I think already for a
lot of his fans would be too far like in
their world that that's easy that
doesn't exist that's not a thing yeah to
call someone a 10 you're establishing
you're attracted to that 10 is like
absolutely ten is like the example he
uses is Megan Fox Okay a lot of guys say
she's a 10 and she's you know Helen of
Troy
launched a thousand ships I would like
this house
his house looks like a [__] Roblox
house
[Laughter]
he's like a baby so it makes sense
that one's sitting there clicking woman
woman woman woman because they think
they're gonna be gay if they do anything
else but they're not actually thinking
about the question what's interesting is
like he won't let it go he put the
question on Twitter and all of his uh
hyper masculine
probably somewhat homophobic fans are
like woman
and what we also let's keep in mind that
this video is 2021 summer of 2021 where
he was known on the internet but far
from like La 2022 was the year that it
became phenomenon okay and a lot of his
new fans so you have to imagine is a
much more like Niche audience that he's
speaking okay okay yeah sure I I that's
true
but he he won't let it go because I
think he has this desire and he he needs
he needs people to understand that he's
not gay for feeling this way right he's
he he needs the world to understand that
he goes they think it's gay but let me
tell you why wrong they're not why
they're wrong right and why it's okay to
have sex with trans women right and of
course it is right
but I'm just trying to no that's like
analyze like there's so many layers to
this but yeah I guess it really is it
really is more layered than Shrek who's
the ultimate onion to unlayer okay I
just watched that for the first time in
a while with Theodore did he like it the
OG truck
um I don't know if he made it all the
way through it's it's hard to get him
through a whole movie okay it's a good
movie though I liked it I love that that
first you've always liked Shrek you've
always had an affinity for sure I love
me some Shrek
back to uh this ogre
I think they're going to be gay if they
do anything else but they're not
actually thinking about the question you
didn't know it's not gay you need to
think about it more
riddle trust me yeah it's a riddle we
need to untangle this it's not gay I
promise you
so smart I operate on so many levels I'm
so smart I figured out how I can have
sex with a trans girl and it not be gay
oh [__] dude higher than the average man
you people are not thinking about the
question
when I say a one and a 10 I mean
Megan Fox with a dick
that's the [__] or Hulk Hogan with a
[__]
uh
it's okay bro you can you can have sex
with a trans person it doesn't make you
I mean the whole it just doesn't let's
not don't the classification doesn't
matter bro
just be your true authentic self my dude
which he goes on to say in a second shut
up okay okay
that's the girl this is the question I'm
asking Megan Fox or Hulk Hogan so you're
thinking well I don't want to be gay so
oh I just I clicked the girl the number
one did it you're gonna [__] Hulk Hogan
okay Mr [__] but he's got mustache and
muscles and [__] oh hairy okay so like
he's really and so invested in this
analogy it's like out of nowhere I mean
this man
is trying to justify he really is trying
to convince himself that deep down he's
not gay this is what's happening
big dude six foot five
it's pretty gay to me that's something
pretty bad I don't care okay he's making
Fox okay he's got a dick but maybe you
can like
scoot it
out the way I'm still making this
you know what I'm saying at least she's
small and [__] and get your hand around
her neck so what are you doing
he just said the part that really brings
us to a whole nother level okay let me
go back
out the way I'm still making Fox
you know what I'm saying at least she's
small and [__] and get your hand around
her neck mess her up okay so what
yeah it's preferable to sleep with trans
women because I can beat them up
if they're ten right because if they but
just like that's like like he he kind of
like that's the like the rationale in
his mind is like I can't beat up Hulk
Hogan the the the the predominant
qualifier is that he can overpower them
right beat them up the way that he does
with women which he knows is also the
case with a [__]
you ain't messing up Hulk Hogan Hulk
Hogan's gonna mess you up so this is the
question I'm asking you need to operate
on a higher plane think about this bro
how does he wear this shirt it's so
tight like his circulation has got to be
getting cut off like that thing is just
tight as could be
okay think about this this is important
this is cultural
this affects the world we now live in
what is straight what is gay it's all a
big sliding Spectrum isn't it yeah
because you're gonna sit here go oh no
no it's gay to bang Megan Fox with the
dick I counter that argument it's gay to
bang Hulk Hogan with a [__]
which one is it
okay well
it's like literally on that is so wild
I mean this is really Progressive
frankly what he's Prof he's putting
forward at the end there is like guys
right that's the thing is it's like
there's it's this bizarre interweaving
of like a very like kind of open
Progressive mindset about sexuality and
also like it's being motivated by Deep
misogyny of like I I need to be able to
beat the [__] out of whoever I'm
sleeping with
it reminds me of like a religious person
who's secretly gay like I'm getting
those vibes like he's gonna try to pray
away the gayness or something and well
loophole the gay loophole right yeah
it's like how you're still virgin if you
only do anal right like it's a loophole
it's a god loophole
uh
yeah pretty interesting though but I
like the wokeness at the end he's like
listen it's all on the Spectrum let's
just be let's just love his love
right which he made he said Love Is Love
he may have sincerely thought at the
time
um I don't think he would say any of
these things today like I don't think
like again this was 2021 before he
really like struck
figurative goal I guess literal gold
with the audience that he found then he
had to get back in the closet
unfortunately yeah I don't think uh I
don't think he would say the same today
hey Zach uh
Nelly
Nails
says she's 21 years old Zach
I'm 21. [__] you that's what she asked
for
Logan says Hey podcast with peace and
love can you please wish my girlfriend
happy birthday
we bonded over the podcast we've been
together for almost three years and had
a beautiful baby I love that
congratulations you guys
Love Is Love
yes sir
thank you for the five gifted JoJo here
actually is so this may surprise you but
he actually built this in Roblox before
he built it in real life
that's smart
you know just to feel it out and he
liked the way it looked in the game so
he built it yeah
there it is
so I guess congratulations
um to Andrew Tate for
uh saying love is love it's day to bang
Hulk Hogan with a [__]
okay I mean it's an interesting Theory
I'm so smart
this is the Nick Fuentes I've heard this
so many times Nicks Fuentes
if you think about it having sex with
women is pretty gay
I'm a virgin
with a dick which means I'm straight I
don't know these guys they get wrapped
up in pretzels
somebody uh Elwood in the chat said uh
he would 100 say those things today and
he'd just try and Rebrand it as Ultra
Alpha yeah I mean like you just said
with the Nick maybe maybe he'd find a
way to
I don't know I don't know it just again
because this was before
like he really got on that the Matrix is
silencing me red pill [__]
uh I don't know how it would really fly
with this current audience and before he
found Allah as well
is not down with that [__] I mean right
AB I mean in general
that's true I guess when you go
conservative enough everybody's not down
with it
uh so there it is and he's not he is not
a reformed he went hardcore Islam I
think he's like well
all right
did we was there ever any evidence of
him being
faithful other than him just saying I'm
a Muslim now there's clips of him in a
mosque and stuff okay I don't know if
that proves anything but he seems pretty
sincere about it
well apparently uh he was trying to flee
to uh to Dubai to escape the uh the
charges in Romania and so maybe he does
not maybe he was trying to ingratiate
himself
uh in the Middle East so that he
wouldn't get extradited or something I
don't know
I don't know here's the words of the
Andrew Tage stand he goes never seen
Star Wars none of them never will oh my
God you're missing out maybe
you're missing out on being a
multi-millionaire keep your movie
I don't think you understand
what it means to be a millionaire
but uh
I mean I I mean
you got time you can you have time to do
stuff
you should anyway but ignore the
construction I'm rebuilding my Mansion
you'll see when it's done we'll do an
episode of cribs I had to this area here
yeah it's pretty interesting though
isn't it it just it just surprised me
oh this Dono from Master go says Hey
guys first time Dono here I'm the guy in
the shirtless Eddie Tick Tock this is
the guy who was sitting next to him I'm
assuming
Eddie's the nicest guy ever I'm so glad
you guys found him Papa bless thank you
bro thanks for setting up that call
that's Austin from Boston I I am
assuming otherwise I don't know what
else he's talking about oh
but uh I'm assuming that's him yeah
so there that is
you people are not thinking about the
question
um
you know we talked about this plunger
Dan had a lot of uh reservations about
it I actually didn't think you could
break through it
this is a plunger it's like some
Japanese thing you push on it
or Korean you push on it and it unplug
unplugs I could use one of those right
now
but Dan was saying well what if your
hand goes through I said that plastic
looks pretty
looks pretty strong
[Music]
can you imagine there's a big ass
[__] turd in there
and the thing is you're pushing real
hard so you're just gonna stomp it
[Music]
was a disaster
so nasty
so yeah do not use those um
do not use those
tough crowd
do not come zero points that are
subreddit
this is actually pretty cool the iceberg
lore I'll be honest I know most of these
some of them I didn't know like all the
way at the bottom I was like what the
[__]
so I think this is a good road map for
our lore series kind of to start
at the top is peace and love friend
meets the crew foot soldiers family
Layer Two is White Cloud Gabe Pride
minute prolapse anus Jersey Outlaw
hairline King lovebot
layer three wiki feet 800 DPI Flocka
shout out to your family
Ethan is 42 5 Street steamy Awards
scorpion chair majority female audience
audio adiato Wan
triller lawsuits
all right we're getting a little bit
deep here now A B boxing match PNP
weights and fish zilizanka 20 billion
dollar compound av's origin story
Godfather impression Joker brand Amy
burrito
off the rails intro bomb threats Dr IDs
I'm I know all of these I think most of
us know all this stuff
we probably don't need a a street lore
video on the bomb threats by the way
people need the lore though that is
important more there's plenty of
commentary channels that have already
covered it that's fair enough you know
so we're getting to the bottom of the
iceberg now we got does Harvey Weinstein
look like or just rank Kevin I look like
Harvey Weinstein Lou
yeah Ethan body double throwst Saudi
benefactor that's not fraud R Kelly
passport song Chestnut Gabe The Chew
Zone apology Podium beautiful world
beautiful world I'm 100 I know all these
yep easy
going down another layer Mayo memes Brad
the bull I just peed in my basement the
band of Ethan klein.com that one's a
deep cut that one probably should be
lower I agree
Andrew Tate cease and desists see that's
yeah content Court Don arcs Arab world
news
all right now we're getting really low
to the Twilight Zone
AI Ian Nathaniel klansman Muhammad
uh
Wally the mole people hunger FF deep
fake Jay-Z intro oh no Sam Cedar the
feeding window bull penis
I'm right 100 I know everything
Barefoot and then going even deeper
Barefoot brother Drive
this smells like my butthole candle dude
whoever wrote this really knows their
[__] uh-huh DD Mega doo doo Vape God nft
Gatsby 808 hot meme
how do they remember all this [__]
like how do you even recall it all I
mean I know all this stuff but to make
this list I don't know if I could do it
Ben Affleck's back tattoo gerd gang
Swami
Wendy William fartgate
now we're going deep deep Dan had hair
that's rude no I mean you'd have to be a
long time Watcher at this point to even
remember that arrow that is a long time
I would move some of these around like
Mobility marries not that deep
ghost stories I mean it's been a while I
agree though some some should definitely
be moved around
um like think things like the mole
people that's really absolutely that's
like a chat meme live stream that has
only come up a couple times you know
that's that's pretty deep
uh wait mastergo said no I'm the guy
that got shirtless Eddie to go to a
construction site without his shirt on
I have what is it I don't know what he's
talking about remember that one I've
been talking about recently doing
collabs keep it up team
well thank you for the Dono and thank
you he says I'm the one from the video I
don't know what he's talking about thank
you though construction site without I
mean we've watched so many maybe we did
watch that one and I'm just forgetting
but for to say I'm the guy from the
video it's like right yeah
not the video I don't know what it is
thank you though
um
where were we uh
uh Dan had hair Dan had hair Mobility
Mary ghost stories inspired by the
Howard Stern Show Dr Fidel deleted
segment oh that's that's a real that
should be like that's like bottom of the
that Iceberg that's Mariana Trench yeah
that's a good one though Bronco brazzo
Zach's lawn [__] and the intern
PowerPoint so I got a piece of bad Bell
Delphine spit jar Mr Beast cease and
desist
what the [__] was the Mr BC synthesis
that's the first one I'm a little [__]
yeah Asian I mean it sounds familiar to
me but what was that nobody remembers
where was it Mr B cease and desist oh
that's my website
um when we did the website for that goof
the the Willy Wonka goof
I left that off
he said this is because you yeah copied
his website okay that is really deep
yeah that's really deep that's a good
one going down even further Patrice
Wilson countdown stream shoe nice just
shoe nice just shoe nice in general
Credence Klein water reversion
curse anal fissures
The Bachelor Leonard katzman that's
really deep yeah little Tracy beef
that's really deep
Fatburger oh no that's Steve it just got
brought up again goof gang
um Sharky's gift card
almost to the bottom the dunk the drunk
stream blocked on Twitter by OJ Chet
Hank's threats trailer lawsuit Lost
episode
trailer lawsuit Lost episode that was oh
episode we had to delete him off the
rails we were still on Zoom
yeah I don't think we even it never was
even like it wasn't just that it was
deleted we just didn't post it what
happened because we recorded we sent it
to your lawyer and he was like I can't
post this okay okay you were trying not
to be sued at the time too right it was
before we've done I think we've done way
worse now
objectives have shifted yes exactly Bert
Kreischer Lost episode that's a d That's
like a very that is super deep yep uh
I'm not gonna read that one Bill Burr
episode one
yeah that's yeah just like 10 videos
about it so I don't know if that the
wild card's identity
we know who that is we know we know the
Wild Card Sam that's interesting how
long we've come okay now
the this is Brock bottom
Cody padrino that's the guy who came to
my house right
John William Kirby Kelly who the [__] is
I don't know the [__] that is so I know
the answer to that John William Kirby
Kelly maybe I'll type it to you in case
you don't want to say go ahead
oh I'm I know this too yeah yeah
oh [__] so I I don't I didn't recall his
name at all yeah it rang a bell when I
saw it but when I looked it up yeah yeah
I mean I already said his name I don't
care he's the guy he's like the Neo-Nazi
white supremacist who got arrested for
swatting me and others
all the time sorry bro and then voice
Flamingo R I I don't I have no idea none
um we were talking about it yesterday
did we did we figure that one out or
were we all lost on that one
it's so deep even uh it's too deep
maybe somebody in the chat will remember
voice Flamingo r
chat said we posted the Lost episode for
members can we post oh [__] no that
shit's dead I'm not just long gone I'm
not bringing any of that [__] I think it
was complete maybe I don't know
because I think we found out during
recording that we should just hold off
she's also died
oh wow that is that is Steve that is how
what bottom of the trend so how is that
well we talked about the the three this
yeah we have talked about it just not by
name probably I've never heard that name
but okay I guess that is D so deep I
never heard of it it's someone from I
shouldn't say it I'm going to say
something I don't read it who is a crazy
obsessed hater that claims I'm a pedo
and thinks I'm essentially the devil he
is the original of swirls in chat
yeah we've looked at it on the show
there was like some conspiracy oh I
remember the like insane images that was
them yes so that person is serious
seriously ill very seriously seriously
yeah
chapter is Reddit account I'm curious
what they've been up to
England
your shirt's kind of got some spirals on
it today oh [__] oh [__] no there's no
complete spiral they're just they're
Wiggly
that would be good enough for him
there's another coincidence
um here is
what is this episode lengths this is
unrelated but I just find this
interesting someone sent me this just a
bunch of details about the podcast in
general episode length uh episodes most
used words how many episodes per month
I'm surprised there's not like a sharper
increase in length because I feel like
it used to be two hours and now it's
like three and a half oh wait that's
yeah scroll to the right
uh
it's like a scroller okay
okay I see I guess yeah it did increase
it's cool fat
calendar I don't know what that is let's
see
581 episodes we have to have more than
that a lot more than that
so average duration 2 hours 17 minutes
episodes per month seven no
average size zero megabytes
title World Cloud this is interesting so
what is this I wonder how they put this
together
Ace family A B Andrew back band Bell
Charles Court
dark I guess after dark David Delphine
Ethan family Frenemies H3 H3 TV
leftovers keemstar
these are ones that I guess that are a
little bit above trending
okay
cool
I guess
thanks
that was awesome
it's kind of interesting
finder it's kind of interesting kind of
important
kinda
uh
just I'm just out of curiosity check
their account I want to know if there's
anything any psycho [__] to look at I'm
I get
I get a kick out of that stuff oh see
that that's not funny apparently they're
just
whatever not funny stuff
but um what is the chances that that
account is run by somebody I know in
real life
someone I've met
someone potentially I've been in the
same room as hmm
is it possible
that it might be someone you've met
before someone close to you
someone you never expected what is this
voice that's like Twilight Zone you're
Rod Sterling yeah
thank you
if you're still holding yeah
I don't know if I cut it though wait
what did you want me to button out you
type it
Ian said button I just panicked and
pressed it I don't even know what about
I think it might have been good yeah I
mean it couldn't have hurt it was
definitely a good button moment
did it cut the whole Rod Sterling thing
probably I'm not yeah all right well we
we had a button moment and I don't even
know what about but
Ian said button and I don't ask
questions I just slam I trust them you
know what I mean we're avoiding but
landmines here today folks
sure good to have a button
I wish I could take this button out with
me in the world
The Time Machine dude I wish sometimes
you have a at a party
say something a little silly wish you
had a button
I I appreciate your enthusiasm to slam I
didn't expect you to press the button I
was kind of just saying it well I
figured I figured you wouldn't have said
it unless you really meant it well it's
good to know like how responsive you
were there because you're not you said
when you said notes usually it's serious
you're not you don't like joke around
Discord you're busy oh I never joke
and Discord yeah
so if you said button I trust that so
don't abuse that power again
I would never although it wasn't I don't
think it's a bad call
but it's better to err on the side of
caution right I suppose so I have no
idea what a cut
but it's fun either way
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
you shouldn't have said it Dan I
buttoned it okay well fair enough you
you know what I mean that but that
button was Dan's fault
see now I don't even know what they've
seen because
I'm confused about what like what was
today's show about who knows I don't
know it's all erased it's just uh
so I was explaining about the last
button and then Dad said something I had
to button out
so I don't know what's left
from the audience perspective it's
pretty funny what is the viewing
experience like I'm curious I've clicked
over the stream because every time you
hit it it's 20 seconds of that I know
it's really that you should not have
used it I know I know for comedic effect
but at least I think it's funny people
know what it is and it just it makes
them speculate right I like the mystery
okay okay okay
yeah I don't know what happened guys
don't ask it's just but no push don't
push the button don't push
[Laughter]
no I'm seeing the raw footage
unfortunately okay
chocolate mocha you know Collard cream
yeah they're all different flavors
flavors different flavors flavors we're
gonna get a way to use used to using
that box that's what I'm afraid of and
like yeah with it being a 20-second uh
a 20 second drop out we should really
not do it unless it's super serious and
you shouldn't have said that Dan I
didn't say anything that serious but you
said something it didn't help okay Ian
do you agree with my button in that case
with the original intent of the button
did you agree with what I pushed there
wait when you pressed it to Dan when I
pressed it on Dan yeah sure yeah see
Ian's got my back okay sure
I like the button
it's Dynamic you should have buttoned uh
when you call me dad a minute ago by the
way because they're all making fun of
you for that now Dad I said Dan yeah you
called me dad kind of said that the
audience can't see how dramatically you
hit that button
yeah it doesn't work it won't work that
way it doesn't work like that wait I
don't get it in my record
uh no actually oh as a matter of fact
and so that's something to uh keep in
mind with the uh audio upload oh no
truly how bad you got to cut out Lowe's
timestamps are gonna be off right no
that's actually gonna be fine but you
gotta I'm gonna have to go back and cut
out stuff out of the highlights correct
oh it's not cutting for you
no yeah it's only it's only what goes
out to air
I think if you slide over the timeline
you can see the card at least so you
could hopefully
and the waveform would be different yeah
yeah yeah yeah because I'm getting the
raw recordings afterwards he doesn't see
any of the yeah
I'll figure it out it's a big deal
because again other outside of today
where we're kind of [__] around with
it because it's new it's only going to
be used every once in a while and if if
it's used you'll know what to cut
you know what I mean well there was a
test there was a test and then whatever
just happened
yeah I mean
and right we didn't really need to use
it either of those times to be honest
yeah they want you to see that I'm
slamming it but how else am I supposed
to hit a massive button red that's the
point that's why they make it there's no
mistakes yeah not like a little I'm not
nice thing because it's supposed to be
used in a panic I'm not pushing it like
softly yeah you know
all right welcome everybody welcome back
very good
now if we want to make it to the top
charts we need to step up the excitement
for example take a look at these guys
they are
wrapping up a podcast that they're
shooting in
a cafe or something like the sort
and uh this is the kind of excitement
that we need look at you
it got so quiet in here
what the [__] you know I mean can we
coordinate this
they had a viral moment how how do we
get a viral moment like why is he so
calm he's literally not he's like yeah
you gotta move faster than that bro I
think we're fine
laughs
is this the driver yeah he's like hey
let's watch that again it's quite good
they know the guests for the day
dude it got so quiet in here how should
I
he actually got like slammed this this
dude is really not has no sense of
urgency at all here I mean he's like all
right he's comfortable apparently I
can't even say are you okay
friend fell forward
he may have died yeah that's right
literally his friend he may have died
and so could he he is totally fine right
yeah yeah no injuries
um
I won't lie this is definitely me when
uh car almost hits me
now I want to focus on the driver if I
can
he
kind of inexplicably crashed I think
we're fine I think we got all the audio
on there
oh he's like are you okay okay yeah
how do you do that I'm gonna watch this
again he's driving red lights
he went through a red light so quiet
yeah but it's like it's like Final
Destination he's just trying to kill
them like there's no explanation
bro it got so quiet in here well it
looked like he dodged that white car oh
he dodged the white car I thought we had
this in the dock
the white car hits oh so it's not even
his fault
the girl in the white car made a tick
tock about this there's more lore to
this oh is it in here
oh he was here I didn't know we were
talking about this come say hi
[Music]
hey
come show off come come say hi yeah here
you guys look beautiful
hello
Hi how are you nice to see you thanks
for being here wait hello no why don't
you come sit here okay well so show off
your shoes
hi everyone
we're doing a little shoot for Teddy
fresh downstairs
collection what do you think
um
what's uh what's your Instagram handle
it's Monet m-o-n-e-t McMichael she is
popping popping fashionista she has come
down here to collab with us I'm very
excited
um it's super cool thank you for coming
it's very exciting and I'm glad
you're the send help gang over there I
was just asking her how she found out
about us and it's through the podcast so
I was like oh my God you got to come
upstairs they're literally doing it
right now yeah
can someone link me her Instagram page
so I can open it yeah
Monet McMichael Monet McMichael yep
Mick is that Irish it is
my first my name is French Monet okay
monetary okay there it is
but uh how's the shoot going guys
amazing so good yeah we got some fire
flicks we're on like look three so she's
a natural so anything we put on her
looks fire wait the chat are you guys um
so you can show off the whole outfit
are you guys shooting photos together
like in the same photo
that's fun you guys should do more
together I don't know what's the plan
but I know people will love those
so here is
Monet
showing off our new collections coming
out this Thursday send help
oh yeah we got the button
don't touch it or this whole thing will
be gone we've already been pushing it
too many times today
[Music]
no you guys are great I like it so here
you you show it off I mean you know we
got the whole thing now
work it work it blink twice if you need
help my God
the police are coming if you wear that
in public help me yeah
here's Monet by the way if you guys
Monet McMichael she is popping I love it
uh it's so cool
and um a queen queen Behavior definitely
where are you are you from New York
oh Jersey yeah but I'm like barely in La
so I'm like this is where we came out oh
she came you came out just for this oh
thanks that's so nice
family so monaeus family yeah so we love
that thank you so much
that's exciting you're popping dude 550
followers
they can hear you better
yeah
oh my God that's so nice are you
wait it says
it says here Rutgers nursing but are you
are you doing full-time like fashion
blogging concentration my main platform
is Tick Tock so
um oh yeah I do like send me that you
guys Beauty
now fashion skincare lifestyle so you
were you were doing nursing before yeah
okay I graduated in May I'm gonna keep
that my bio as long as I can yeah I mean
you know why not so let y'all know
because you forgot so how long have you
been able to do this professionally
September was when I was like all right
I'm not going
to girl three million followers on Tick
Tock this is Chris yo this is like
L'Oreal's [__] going on here
we need to get you some fake lash
controversy or something get you paid
for that
Monet Monet McMichael on Tick Tock as
well dang this is awesome thank you so
much for coming oh my god dude you're
popping off on Tick Tock what the hell
that's great I'm happy that's great
thank you let's have fun just in my room
just seeing the world now I'm like what
the heck
what are we doing good I'm I'm very
happy for you I'm so happy thank you for
letting me crash the show and you've got
a whole little uh yeah
yeah the Posse you've got a glass not
necessarily A Glam Squad
more of a
yeah oh you're a manager
[Music]
oh you have a team yeah where did
where's the team come from you work for
like an agency or something yeah we're
they're based in La um oh can you come a
little closer to them yeah just get
right on the race in L.A and it's like
my first time meeting them in person too
yeah okay I signed like top of the year
so like three months in and like it's
just crazy you guys better not [__]
around with her
how many deals they got here they got
you a lot of good deals yeah I mean the
ones that come in hand to handle it like
okay she's a big deal you don't
that's it I'm saying I've seen these
numbers you guys better be getting that
you guys better be hooking her up I'm
not even kidding because there's people
lining up to sign her now oh my gosh you
got an exclusive contract with them or
can you leave at any time
I'm just [__] with you guys I like
the cause of drama know your worth girl
[Laughter]
so uh
JK says I used to work at a summer camp
with Monet hey girl you're killing it
Jamie
wait which summer camp kid Academy I was
I loved like babysitting and like summer
camp and stuff so
that's crazy hey Jamie hi Jamie whoever
you are I love you
so how long are you in L.A until Sunday
so we've been stuffed my schedule
um I have an event tonight which I'm
excited about Vanity Fair like oh I was
like what what is the event it's like
the pre-askar like party so yeah I'm
like I got a little young Hollywood
young Hollywood thanks worthy I'm so I'm
nervous I'm excited and there's no plus
ones I'm like I'll just pull it by
myself no plus one what kind of event is
this you guys couldn't get her a plus
one what are you guys doing no one I'm
just kidding
I'm just I'm just making sure they
working for their money girl you deserve
the best
what's the percentage they're getting
even just having a good time here sorry
I'm sure they're doing a great job we
love them yeah
um
how did you get how did you get started
in the in the kind of like fashion
blogging
um I I feel like Fashion's something I'm
like newly getting into so I'm like this
is so exciting um but I started doing
just like Beauty and hair stuff like
while I was in nursing school just like
it was like an outlet like I would like
run home from school get out my books
and like just film for fun like my
friends I was doing like slow-mos in the
club
um and one of those got traction so you
know I just kept pouring into it and
just like amazing here we are like yeah
like what's going on I mean the same
thing happened to me right like I was
working and just doing comedy for fun
and then it worked it just worked out
that's the best one it's like your
passion too it's like it's all love I
always want just to be fun and like
authentic organic that's it you you made
it the right way the perfect way
[Applause]
she had 2.9 Million followers we had
three oh was that three it was at 2.9 I
thought it was a 2.9 you're lying it
just went up to three
all right I saw people in the chat just
saying it just hit three so I didn't
catch it it was a few days ago the web
browser
it like rounds it off it weirdly you
didn't lose any followers it was like
not 100K really quick check your
followers how are we doing on the
follower account let's pull up the phone
yeah let's take a look everybody go to
Monet
on Tick Tock let's get the family going
we're going to do a live follower check
here today
yeah it does three oh but if you click
it you get the exactly exact yeah oh God
red drum roll
um
I don't think we're getting it drum roll
that's embarrassing all right
well I'm sure it went up good to me you
know what uh
[Applause]
oh do you have do you know someone at
Tick Tock you have a wrap there yeah bro
you get banned like left and right I'm
like them oh my God let him live dude
please okay yeah I love you but I sorry
about everything I said yeah but I need
that yeah
I get keep getting banned every time I'm
on there
because Andrew Tate fans Mass report I
don't know if you're up to date on all
that you guys got to go yeah yeah okay
yay thank you so much so nice to meet
you guys I'm glad you guys popped in
send help
it's actually true like please get me
out of this send help
Monet McMichael what a nice what a nice
uh fun experience we love her yeah I'm
so excited to see those photos
she's so cool
that's such an honor that someone like
so cool in fashion wants to come work
with us that's great
I don't think her manager liked me very
much I think he did he seemed Charmed
listen I know what it's like in this Biz
you know you sign up with the first
person and then all of a sudden you your
things are happening and you're like
well how did I end up in this situation
you know I just got to speak to her as
good you know uh you know
Mano imano two I've been through it girl
you know what I mean
I don't care if he's standing there now
he knows now he knows his ass is on thin
[__] ice
hmm
you know what I I think I I get off a
little bit on making those kind of
people squirm because they always come
in here trying to they they come in here
trying to handle and they're trying to
like be all PR and [__] and you know
they don't do anything their job
literally is to do nothing just skim off
the top you you should have seen the
liver Kings management team behind the
scenes that's I love that's my favorite
they were pacing around trying to get
them out of there as soon as possible
great
it's my favorite thing I love when you
were talking to Papa John's guy I don't
remember if he's an attorney or manager
or what it was but that was great when
Papa called in Papa called in yeah I
don't remember that right yeah it wasn't
not when it came in but when he like
zoomed in once and like
you noticed that somebody was in the
room okay and you were like wait let me
talk to this that's my favorite when I
noticed someone's like hovering I'm like
who the [__] are you dude and we had a
great moment like that with Tai Lopez
what he had lawyers casing us remember
right yeah day two
she's awesome I love her shout out
okay that was a fun little intermission
slay
slave clock
so anyway uh guys can we set up a car
crash or something oh yeah get me the
follow-up to this love you're you said
there's like more lore to it I'm not
finding it I'm trying to find a tick
tock but basically the girl said she was
driving the white car and that the Black
Card uh drove uh drove the red light
oh right that makes sense that makes
sense
you can see the walk signal too okay
that makes sense interesting yeah it
says one
okay hold on okay oh yeah yeah no if it
said one zero it goes yellow once not
it's I think that says nine
yeah eight one here yeah plus that's a
seven six oh [__]
yeah yeah that's full-blown run the
whole all the receipts are here
let's go
yeah he ran the red light man you just
got caught red-handed podcast
um
let's go let's go that's right
I love it
yeah Ian you got to step it up with the
sketches and stuff I mean I need me a
viral moment like that put an anvil over
my head or something
got a sandbag a light or something yeah
a light a sandbag dude
that'd be awesome put a sandbag up there
we can like pre-cut the table so it hits
it breaks it in half
I wonder if we could get some
Prosthetics so it looks like my arm is
dislocated or something right
maybe what we can do is talk about it on
the show everybody knows that we're
staging it and then when we do it you
all put it out in the world like it's
real everybody play along and flip it
and ship it clip it and ship it people
clip hidden jib it I genuinely think we
could have a viral moment here
I
do so here's the other angle I guess
is awesome
love this so much
sitting in a cafe
wait you were you you tick-tocked that
[__] you didn't you didn't even move
from Safe People You Gotta you gotta
sorry I know that's what he was doing
hold on I gotta record this I almost
died dude I noticed this too go back to
the first video yeah
his first instinct is to open the camera
app on his phone you can see it open up
uh what the [__] oh here Hyrule moment
yeah so here if we get his this angle
again
um
the calm guy so we're wondering why he
didn't move I think we found out why he
was opening his Tick Tock
broom hits my car thinking thinking oh
this is good
he may have been sandwiched squished
death yeah it doesn't Jack if his
friends okay that's a million views
right there look maybe he goes to his
phone boom and then ready hold it there
he goes he's logging yeah you're so
right cam
you can see it he went straight look at
this look at this yeah there it is dude
come on your instinct needs to be to
check if your home is okay and to get
out of danger
the check if you're okay it doesn't even
yeah there's no present
self-preservation instincts at all
they've like rewired their survival
instincts because like if I was in the
situation my brain would not go
you have survival instincts to get out
of the way to check that everyone's okay
yeah fight or flight they've been
reprogrammed tick tock tick tock or
flight
Tick Tock is our home that's incredible
what the [__] yes yes
that
this [__] straight to tick tock
I found the girl who was in the crash
too I just saw a good job oh there you
go so if we go back to the new angle
that we've just acquired his video his
tick tock let's take a look it did get
him a lot of views so his in his
intuition was definitely spot on 1.8
million likes there you go so all worth
it buddy
I need to rewire my survival instincts
I just got hit by a car while sitting I
just got hit by your car yeah are y'all
serious what the oh
no way my friend Nathan and I were
recording a podcast with his piano bro I
cannot believe what I'm seeing right now
this is actually more shocking than the
car accident I think the lead is being
buried here right big talk is not going
anywhere
like yeah sometimes I see these videos
and go how is it that he's recording
already like this card just crashed in
right and he's somehow making the tick
tock it almost doesn't make sense I go
who's is this planned while sitting in a
cafe oh my God yeah
wow that is incredible
well done sir well done let's check
these the views on this little plans
right 12 million views he knows what
he's doing there you go he's the man
Sigma Behavior would be wild if his
friend like died though
he's like we just got hit by a car uh
Alex are you okay
this is jugular is all sports
organs are ruptured oh god so let's see
from the girl's Angle now this is all
clout this whole situation is clouded up
so here she is
she only got 160 000 likes loser
I think we got copyrighted music
so she says was it my fault I had the
green
black car how do we know it was her she
didn't show any proof anyone could have
made that video she showed yeah I guess
she showed the car but he has no way to
say it's her so it's potentially she got
like a free Cloud video and she wasn't
even there
you're the real deal girl sorry I
doubted you
maybe if we were faster on the tick dog
draw you would have got more than three
million views
wait someone's saying he's in chat
uh he wants that clout
the dude who took the tick tock in chat
what was their name Alex Alexey yeah
that was his name I remember wait are
you there that is according to New York
Post that is his name so wait how long
has he been a member is he if it just
became just now it could be someone just
putting his name in right now but it
also could be him hold on yeah I went to
the YouTube channel is this the same
person how did you get here so fast
you're just yeah
how did you get here so fast it was just
like The Tick Tock you heard
we were talking about you and in 10
seconds you're here you're a member
I respect it what the console is insane
yeah
he's a juicer
you got an instinct dude keep it up man
you just need to roam the street with
your finger on the button like a
look at that yeah the quickest shot in
the west kind of thing looking out for
any fires families
could it be staged
I think that would be super illegal well
so well a million views I've seen people
do worse [__] I don't know how you could
stage getting sideswiped and then
crashing into a cafe right in front
where people are bro they do this in
Hollywood every day yeah
I guess it's possible potentially
that's what we're gonna do
by the way I'm not kidding we should try
to make a viral moment where
something Falls and I get like injured
and then see if people eat it up
we'll see if we can rig something up
I thought of a random idea when you said
that there should be a punishment for
pushing the button I just realized that
that would be way better
like so I don't know but I want I
encourage people to push the button I
don't want any hesitation I know but the
button you know what I mean
yeah I'll be like Oh I'm gonna get
punished uh but I said something
horrible I don't know what to do it's
not it's not perfect
that's not perfect no someone said Ethan
is a paid actor that's well that's true
I am paid
by myself
I don't know if that's a conspiracy
um
Avatar you guys this is great news
especially for all you guys in the
podcast I know you're all huge fans
huge news Avatar uh two way of water is
releasing digitally
with three hours of bonus materials so
yes six and a half hours run yeah
[Applause]
that'll get you through a whole work day
six and a half hours
of underwater Adventure so I I assumed
from the headline it's like bonus
features and stuff right not
not what I hope it is which is a six and
a half hour cut of the film less is more
sick less is more not an avatars don't
give me everything go big epic
filmmaking Nobody Does it like James
Cameron that's right so Amanda who's a
fupa Trooper said I sh showed lxc
he was on here
oh okay so you're telling them he's got
eyes and ears everywhere he's like the
the master of Whispers this man's got
tendrils all over the kingdom yeah
good job buddy you you deserve that
Viral one man
if your buddy died it probably wouldn't
be more views but buddy next time
consider that next
Casey neistat in chat that's not true
that guy's too busy to watch a podcast
Casey neistat once told me the most
depressing thing ever and I realized I
don't not only not like him I will never
be like him and I don't want to be like
him he told me
when I go to bed
I sleep for three hours and I don't set
an alarm clock I set a timer
I set a timer for three hours and I go
to bed
that's my hero
that is so depraved bro
the fact that he uses a timer and not
even alarm clock is so depraved to me
but there he is that's why he's the
ultimate Hustler
Casey neistat
real men sleep three hours a day well AB
how many hours a day are you sleeping
lately I've been sleeping longer I've
been getting like maybe five six hours
so that's like relatively normal yeah
it's good it's on the low side of like
normal I think yeah
mm-hmm good for you yeah women or I mean
women I just saw someone say women in
the chat and read that sleep is
important women are too yeah
I got like eight hours last night me and
Ian went for a hike me I I mean Lena and
Ian yesterday super early so
yeah I got some good you hang out with
any other famous people yesterday you
want a name call name drop I'm talking
about Ian Ian behind me that's really
nice to eat then of you to say that
about me well you are that is a huge
name drop Ian salaried employee he is
verified on Instagram after all Mr the
way you went with famine in on a mega
hike meet Ian and Lena okay where'd you
guys hike uh Griffith Park oh that's
beautiful yeah it was really nice
did you the one that you were told me
you were running yeah but you guys
didn't run did you uh we did a run we
didn't go as long as I did on Saturday
but we did a run can you run in you can
do like kind of like mile runs I don't
know
that's the word I would use of what
happened yeah I tried jog that's good
you jog it was a jog there was some
jogging yeah that's awesome good for you
guys
come next time
here we go do I want a cup
[Music]
or a shirt that says like Fu Philly D
I'm gonna go on a hike with everyone but
him now
I forget why we're in beef why are we
made filling beef
I totally forgot
I just remember that we're beefing
large button
wait really it's that bad no but just
let's move on I genuinely don't remember
things up right now
oh I remember I remember yeah okay I'm
loving your excitement to use the button
it's good to know your ears perked up
dude this button is gonna change
everything I am not gonna hesitate
button button
also I want speaking of influencers who
are family this uh
uh Instagram or I don't know if she's
also in ticket but herself
somebody all might know her you saw this
Ray Olivia
look at this queen of makeup she's so
awesome it was so cool she said
It's So Random and not what I usually
post about but I ordered some free
samples of gamer Subs through the HD
podcast had to pay a few kid for
delivery and oh my God this mango one
tastes so good honestly thought it would
taste too artificial but to me it tastes
just like mango juice
[Applause]
the mango is my favorite it's so good
so we love soap as well I gotta try the
mango one I don't think I don't know if
I've tried it it's so good you got so
hung up on the black cherry and you
haven't really you don't know the full
bread you could Branch out the gamer sup
Nation
um
there it is so avatars
so
it's coming out rejoice when it comes
out on digital will you watch it all six
and a half hours you don't have nothing
better to do do you think in that
extended footage there's like a sex
scene or something I think the whole
that's what the three hours is it's just
one sex scene dude do you think avatars
have orgies where they all entangle
their [__] I mean very Primal yeah I
mean do you think they ever get knotted
up and then it's like yeah knotted up
yeah dude free for all
the idea of the tangles makes me
nauseous like it's gross to me
foreign
like disgusting
you're gonna tangle up nah you've seen
like the the Avatar like fleshlights and
[__] like that yeah yeah the uh the Bad
Dragon ones you know the dildos I don't
know if I've seen an avatar Bad Dragon
but I know I know that brand wild it's
pretty [__] Wild
all right well let's talk about
one of our main stories today we've got
the Elon Musk dude Elon Musk you know
everybody knows he's a piece of [__] but
he really outdid himself recently on uh
Twitter
it was actually a pretty big story so
some of y'all may be familiar with it
but
um Elon had an exchange with a
I guess current or X employee I guess
that was part of the reason this guy
um Hallie now a little background on
this guy I don't know I don't know if
I'm saying his name right he's Icelandic
right
and so this guy's like a saint
he sold his company
to Twitter
and they had some kind of a contract
with him where he would remain employed
first whatever part of their amount of
time yeah and that's very frequent when
companies buy they employ the owners
just to help transition if they make it
like very lucrative for them
and it's like a a win-win kind of thing
so they bought his company
this guy was voted Man of the Year in
Iceland
he's in a wheelchair because he has um
what's it what what's his uh condition
muscular uh dystrophy so he has musk
muscular dystrophy which is a
progressive disease so it gets worse and
worse
as you'll see
now this man he didn't know if he was
still with Twitter or not and actually
he has a good reason to ask because he
has a contract that probably says if he
gets terminated they own a bunch of
money correct
and so he says Dear Elon Musk he tags
him nine days ago the access to my work
computer was cut along with about 200
other Twitter employees however your
head of HR is not able to confirm if I'm
an employee or not you've not answered
my emails maybe if enough people retweet
you'll answer me here
so I think Elon saw this as a slight
like he's trying to embarrass him but
I think this is totally legit because
first of all
if you don't get any explanation from HR
or anything
and you know Elon Musk is such a [__]
he's always on Twitter always this is
the best way to reach him and you know
he's always going through his mentions
so this actually was a fairly reasonable
attempt and it worked by the way he was
right
I don't think what he expected was that
Elon would uh react the way he did
perhaps maybe he would just DM him or
something or say or all of a sudden
after doing that he would get a call
from HR right that would be a reasonable
thing it's like Elon sees this and then
Rings up his HR department and is like
hey handle this I mean his original uh
message is like let's see
it's a tiny bit snarky but like
completely warranted nine days ago the
access to my computer was cut along with
200 other people and nobody's told us
anything like he's entitled to the Stark
yeah
and as a reasonable business owner
you'll be like okay this is not a good
situation let me take a look and and fix
this
he responds what work have you been
doing it's like it's your [__]
company you [__] do a little tiny bit
to investigate this no
he says I would need to break
confidentiality to answer this question
if uh if you if you have your lawyer
sharing writing then I can do it I'd be
happy he says you're approved go ahead
what a dick I think that's like Pro like
exactly he doesn't even want to discuss
it openly you're approved go ahead it's
just like
he's nothing to him exactly he wants to
have this conversation publicly on
Twitter he wants this because he's going
to teach this guy a lesson
he says among other things led the
effort to save about 500 000 in one SAS
contract supported closing down many
others LED prayer prioritizing of design
projects across the company make sure we
were able to deliver with a small team
yada yada he lists his job description
which for some reason Elon wants him to
do it's absolutely [__] insane
right is the implication here that if
you say the that you're doing enough
here you're not fired
like I'm gonna I'm gonna decide whether
you're fired like he's not going to
bother like looking into it to actually
answer the question it's like I'll
actually just decide if you're fired or
not right now based off of your response
it that's a good that's a good question
what is he he says what have you been
doing like to what end are you asking
the question
he just wants to know if was he let go
or not yeah
if you amuse me we shall decide here on
Twitter
up or down it's a lame okay so he lists
all this stuff
Elon says level up from what design to
what Pixar didn't happen
picture it didn't happen when was the
last time you heard that phrase
it's your company dude
since AI how dysfunctional are is are
you
picture it didn't happen
so he's calling him a liar essentially
we haven't hired design rules in four
months calling him a liar what changes
did you make to help with the youth see
he's essentially calling him a liar
and then he posts this clip from Office
Space
one of my favorite movies and you know
what's ironic
there's a deep irony here he posted a
clip they said what do you do you do
here they were doing interviews of the
staff and this one guy had like a super
redundant job he's like I hand the paper
to the assistant and then the sister
brings it to the the engineers Tom
Sakowski oh there you go Zach and they
go what do you say exactly you do here
and of course super patronizing they
fire him implying that this guy does
nothing and he is a fraud
and that he needs to be let go
insanely [__]
the idea of a of a
owner talking this way
publicly to employ
it it's psycho I mean it's psychotic it
really is it's like such a weird
disregard for basic human decency it
really highlights what a psycho he
really is a psychotic person
this man has no [__] empathy
and it's all ego 100 ego no empathy
he responds to be clear you have every
right to lay me off that's totally fine
and fair but usually people are told
when this happens maybe with a letter or
something which didn't happen for nine
days despite multiple emails to you and
others again very reasonable he's like I
don't care I'm not asking to keep
working here just tell me he keeps it
what the [__] so professional this
entire time and it's and this is like
the rudest [__] thing I'm telling you
if you've seen this movie you know the
irony of course
is that these guys who are essentially
they're kind of like anti-villains
they're funny and they're like ruthless
but they do one particular thing that's
so [__] up there's this guy Milton
that works in the basement
and they're like oh we we let we
resolved the issue and they're like oh
well we need to tell him he's fired
they're like no no no no
we resolved the issue we're not going to
tell him he's fired we just want him to
keep working
and he'll find out when he doesn't get
payroll I want the free work this is
what he's doing
I actually forgot that that's how that
goes down the movie you're so right look
at them extra layer of iron he's like he
burned himself so hard wow that's such a
good point I totally forgot that that's
how it plays out yeah I told Bill I did
not get my check Bill Lundberg so it's
all it's like a comedically evil thing
and he's basically saying that he is
them that's such a good observation that
also is what led to Milton burning down
the building
yeah exactly I love that's one of my the
best movies I love it so much it's a
good one if you all haven't seen office
space definitely it's it's so good
so he says but as I shared I finally got
confirmation that I am not an employee
anymore so they did fire him and they
didn't tell him and they ignored his
request
of course I don't think they were privy
to the fact that he had a termination
agreement says again that's totally
within your race no complaints but can
you make sure I get paid what I owed
Elon responds
the reality is that this guy
who was independently wealthy what's
interesting is he somehow figured out
that he's independently wealthy but
simultaneously didn't figure out any
status or details of his employment in
his company and isn't a I mean he's very
he's wealthy because he was seen
valuable enough that Twitter paid him a
lot like independent in this case it's
really not independently he's wealthy
because of Twitter as the richest man in
the world I one I'm wondering what is
your point right are you are you like
wealth shaming him
the reality is this guy who's bitching
who's super rich like why are you
complaining like what what is he trying
to say right
did no actual work he says he did no
actual work claimed as his excuse that
he had a disability so he's lying about
having muscular dystrophy
yeah this is where it immediately is
like any employment lawyer is looking
this and this is a lot money signs money
signs he's like explicitly like talking
about his disability and why he's firing
him yes so
I've we've started we have a HR
Personnel in Teddy fresh or they she
manages both of our companies so I'm
learning more and more about this stuff
you cannot
fire somebody because of their
disability you cannot do that yeah
period and he's explicitly said publicly
that he using his disability as an
excuse right
implying it's part of the reason why he
did not work and needs to be fired
this is an employment this is a
wrongful termination slam dunk yeah
and when this guy has like a massive
contract too they're Mega [__]
so so he go he says
the reality is this guy who's
independently wealthy did no actual work
claimed as his excuse that he has a
disability that prevents him from typing
yet will simultaneously tweeting up a
storm
can't say I have a lot of respect for
that of course this and who is
apparently a genius cannot
cannot fathom a world where somebody
with with a disability can type
disability and also just calling out
somebody for he's tweeting up a storm
like as if like he's not doing any work
he's tweeting all day what do you do he
didn't tweet that much he really was
like all Elon does is tweet all day so
does that mean you do no work
disabled well he we know he doesn't
right but like it's just of all the
people in the world to say that but he's
wrong this guy kept it really succinct
also I am disabled
that's what he said to Elon
so
this is like actually [__] nuts I
mean
what's interesting is yeah you may have
really put this guy out if he has
trouble typing to make him write all
this to your dumb ass but I do think
that people would I mean people with
disabilities can type
I mean they have voice to text there's
voice all kinds of things like dude
you're aren't you the technologist voice
to text is so easy and immediate
like
but
uh Alex this is someone else I guess
who's interacting it's obvious he did
all middle management work from The
Exchange but I personally would not put
an ex-employ on blast and force them to
prove their worth in front of 100
million people
here's Elon Musk
refusing to back down he says he has a
prominent active Twitter account and is
wealthy again what's with the wealth
you're the richest man in the world what
are we talking about singling out the
wealth word
thank you
the reason he confronted me in public is
to get a big payout
he literally just said am I employed and
you made this whole conversation public
right
from what I've been told he's done
almost no work for the past four months
middle management or otherwise despite
his claims on Twitter that he did work
turns out he told HR that he couldn't
work because he couldn't type but was
over the same period typing up a storm
on Twitter checkmate
got him yet there are many people on
Twitter defending him this hurts my
faith in humanity
this guy is the biggest loser I mean
what a [__] ruthless you should I
mean what do you say you're a loser yo
boba
huh yeah do you want anything [__] yeah
I want Boba you guys want boba
yeah
too that would be great because she's
not sure which one she wants wait let me
see the menu
good thank you you can show now I just
took it off the screen I don't want
people to know we're ordering from
um Boba what kind of boba I love Boba
I love Boba me too
sometimes the bulb is not sweet enough
I don't like that when it's like
tasteless
this place is uh pretty consistently
good though yeah oh you know the spot
yeah I have one okay everyone but you
Cam no
yeah of course just to just type what
you want and um thank you Lena you'll
handle that one
will you handle it yeah should we tell
you what we want okay thank you so much
of course honeydew milk tea that's looks
it's green I'm kind of into that eh
honeydew milk tea that sounds good it's
green that's probably a pretty good one
honeydew milk tea I want that one uh you
know honey do milk tea yeah please okay
what does Blended mean Olivia it's like
ice Blended is it hard to get the bulb
out of the ice no no wait the boat is at
the bottom yeah and yeah I know the Boba
is in a blended drink you probably have
to specify that you want boba in that
one by the way there's boba in the
picture okay
yeah
because not all of them do so
should I get extra Bubba
they kind of go heavy on boba in my
opinion yeah there's plenty of them can
you give me the large size Lena yeah
thank you
thank you so much
anybody else
if anybody else wants anything yeah you
typing it type it and then the chat I
want the actually I don't want milk in
mine I want oat milk in mine
okay I'll do oh instead are you are you
doing this on the website because I'm
looking at all the options you could do
like Easy Ice I love that
you know yeah I'm doing it up the the
same site I sent you
so yeah easy on the ice oat milk maybe
I'm feeling a
50 sweet hell yeah not a hundred percent
sweet you understand are you gonna milk
them out
oh I can get you can get flavored Boba
all different flavors mango popping Boba
yeah you can do whatever you want yeah
it's like how do I pick the popping Boba
it's kind of different than regular Boba
it has like liquid on the inside
have you
though
I've been like
I've been on that Bubba [__] for a
minute Ian you described to your drink
as dirty is that really how you order it
no that that's what it's called it's
called a dirty matcha yeah it comes with
a shot of espresso you dirty boy you
dirty boy oh I want dirty I want mine
dirty
I want two shots of espresso extra dirty
you see you got it thank you Lena just
to prove you guys wrong I'm doubling
down all right Elon Musk
there goes our other toilet
I forgot all different flavors well all
that espresso might loosen things if you
know okay this is exciting we got Boba
on the way everybody
I love the Jimmy Lee casual flavors
flavors yeah it's fun but you have to be
like
you have to know the original meme to
even know why that's funny chocolate
mocha you know colored cream yeah
they're all different flavors he's so
casual different flavors
[__] dude flavors yeah that now that's
where we all began all different flavors
flavors different flavors flavors
flavors flavors flavors
all right back to Elon Musk everyone got
their Boba ordering yeah they were good
great
bubble party
thank you love me some Bob Bubba now
Bobby
Bobby I love Beau blacks Bowie blowby
wait is it blacks bogey like Kobe
it's below me I wonder if blowby likes
boba
kill yourself
that is of course Beau Black's uh made a
song Paradise parrot
parroting no it's not pretty
it's support celebrating civil rights
icon celebrating black lives matter
black lives matter wait do it again
no no no no
[Music]
what should that whoa kill
Ed what the [__]
Bobby needed a button
holy [__] bro
you need to go outside yes
you need to go outside and like meet
someone outside of yours like Zoom group
that's bobi by the way we disavowed that
song and the strongest terms possible
should I push it
maybe
um
love says maybe
is it too late at this point I feel like
it might be yeah
I'm just kidding I wasn't really
considering it okay love was feeling it
though love was ready to push the button
dude yeah that's some strong words in
there
it's true
not my words
definitely not I didn't say it
nope
love is what powers and sustains our
country
oh that's very touching actually nice so
Elon Musk continues let's see he says
he's done no work for the past four
months despite his claims oh yeah he
goes people on Twitter are defending him
this hurts my faith in humanity
this guy
who has adoring fans simply because he's
Rich who is
absolutely
degradating mistreating abusing and
employee ex-employee publicly
the people who support Elon Musk are
probably
employees of other people
who If he if their boss did this to them
would not be too happy yet they support
Elon Musk and he's the one that lost his
faith in humanity
I wish Elon was on that [__] Tesla
they launched into space
that would have been a nice end to his
story
he would have gone out the good guy
and just you know what I mean drive off
into the sunset literally
[Music]
[Laughter]
drive into the sun
wouldn't that be a good parallel world
have a good night have a good night
foreign
ERS so um he continues he responds to
this that one that's really crazy hi
again Elon Musk I hope you are well I'm
fine too I'm thankful for your interest
in my health but since you mentioned it
I want to give you more info I have
muscular dystrophy it has many effects
on my body let me tell you what they are
and calmly just destroying him
making him feels tiny which he is
my legs were the first to go when I was
25 years old
I started using a wheelchair it's been
20 years since that happened in that
time the rest of my body has been
failing me too I need help to get in and
out of bed and use the toilet for a long
time I thought my arms would remain
strong a doctor told me they would but
they ended up losing strength which I
don't mind telling you was hard to
accept
but you okay the cards but you okay the
cards you are dealt and I've managed to
create a wonderful life my family is the
best I have two kids see them every day
I recommend that that is
I love that so much that is the most sad
and the next line too
my wife is fantastic strong kind smart
amazing artists I couldn't be happier
with her
about nine years ago I started a company
called
you know dot Co I don't know what the
[__] that is what is that do we know
anything about that company and how much
heat they bought it for uh we don't know
how much they bought it for I saw
speculation that it was just based off
of the number of employees they acquired
uh was like around a hundred they said
100 milli well that's the amount of
employees that the company that's a big
company and uh right yeah and I guess in
the industry it's fairly in in
engineering it's fairly standard a
million dollars per head of like the
company that you're acquiring so people
have thrown out the 100 million figure
but then also uh apparently he people
saw that he had previously alluded to
the deal and that he had taken
significantly less than what other
people had recommended that he'd pick so
I've seen the range from like 25 to 100
million is nice payday yeah
and he took it to work to work on stay
on this project through Twitter right so
instead of like uh uh
being paid out as a company and like
paying capital gains and everything he
chose intentionally to receive that
payment as salary which means he's being
taxed in Iceland where he's from at a
much higher rate
um but he actively wanted to do that
because he's very Pro social services
and everything as we'll see when we
learn about no he's just saying about
him and he fired him had stopped paying
him well that's the yeah except
usually with those kind of contracts if
they get terminated early the entire
amount becomes due upon termination so
Elon being the genius business man that
we all know him to be right
fired him and um
what's the word uh disparaged him
publicly right he says about nine years
ago I started a company called inuo.com
I worked a lot it didn't do my body any
favors but it's what I felt I needed to
do the hard work paid off in the company
became very successful we worked for
more or less every big tech company we
grew fast and made money I think that's
what you're referring to when you say
independently wealthy that I
independently made my money as opposed
to say inherited an emerald mine brawl
let's go oh dude
but after seven years I was tired kovid
was running for longer than the two
weeks you said it would bro he is
there's so much low-key shade he's
[__] good he's laying he's he's this
dude is like in a suit at his gravestone
like celebrating my enemy's death
my body was also continuing to get
weaker after looking at many options I
decided to sell my company
to Twitter financially it wasn't the
best decision my company was making a
lot of money and Twitter's offer was
lower than any smart valuation would say
but like you I made a bet on Twitter
having a lot more potential than it has
had
I joined at a time when the company was
growing fast you kind of did the
opposite
[Laughter]
there was a lot going on the company I
mean that's the fact he Shrunk the
company intentionally so that's and
there was a lot going on the company had
a fair amount of issues but then again
most bigger companies do or even small
companies like Twitter today
anyway I digress are you still reading
or is the bathroom break over hmm
what was I saying oh yes and then you
bought the company and told employees
you weren't firing 70 of them 75 of them
which you then did
I wasn't in favor
of the first batch or the second or the
third or the fourth
I'm not sure which layoff round I was in
there were so many of them
each one came after you promised the
last one was the final one
during my time at the new Twitter 2.0 as
you called it I talked to my manager
every week and asked what I should focus
on and then I proceeded to do those
things every one of them I also
contacted HR regularly and asked if my
job description was correct or needed
updating I wanted to make sure I was
doing what I was supposed to
they said they were looking into it but
I never got a reply
now finally to my fingers which I know
you have great concern for
thank you for that by the way I'll tell
you what I told them I'm not able to do
manual work which in this case means
typing or using a mouse for extended
periods of time without my hands
starting to cramp
I can however write for an hour or two
at a time this wasn't a problem in 200
Twitter 1.0 since I was a senior
director my job was mostly to help teams
move forward give them strategic and
tactical guidance
but as I told HR I'm assuming that's the
confidential health information you are
sharing
bro
[Laughter]
holy [__]
that's true when you tell HR stuff it's
in confidence yeah
and I have to remember in particular
medical stuff like yeah yeah yeah holy
[__] dude
as I told HR I'm assuming that's the
confidential health information you're
sharing I can't work as Hands-On
designer for the reasons outlined above
I'm typing this on my phone by the way
it's easier because I only need to use
one finger I hope that helps let me know
if you're going to pay me what you owe
me I think you can afford it
holy [__] yeah brutal absolutely brutal
and it's it's the burn that he
more than deserved I mean sure yes
outrageous so then here this guy
I follow this guy I've chatted with him
a bit he's the co-owner of Dogecoin we
talked about the former partner partner
right on the show
very nice guy and friendly with Elon I
always see them tweeting
and even he goes I don't think it's a
good idea to [__] on former employees in
public
he's the worst sorry Elon said so and
I'll point out this tweet Elon deleted
yeah because on top of all the other
lawsuit provoking things that he said
him saying he's the worst like that
it's clear like he fired it's personal
he fired him for personal reasons which
is another thing that they could get
screwed for so that tweet's gone right
you can't you can't fire people around
somebody because you don't like them
yeah it's also wrongful although there's
nothing close that doesn't even come
anywhere close to firing someone because
they have a disability right yeah
so let's see
just to give you more details about this
guy he's trashing he was born to A
working class family with a genetic
congenial disease that had him in a
wheelchair by the age of 24. his mother
died when he was 11. when Twitter bought
his company most of the purchase price
was paid a salary to maximize the tax he
would pay for the sale in Iceland out of
support for the country's Social
Services
he then founded a project called ramp up
uh Ray kievic with the goal of building
1500 handicap accessible ramps
throughout the city he was then named
Icelandic Person of the Year by the
country's National broadcaster
that's the guy literally like an icon
he's like a he's like a
he's like the jewel he's like an
Icelandic treasure it's like
oh God
it reminds me it it it's it's genuinely
so much worse too of the time which
really was the I think the first time
that people started to see the cracks in
the cultivated Persona that Elon had
created
um with the kids that were trapped in
the cave in Thailand and he got into it
with the dude who was actually over
there saving the children yeah and
implied he was a pedo and stuff and it
was like a whole thing and that was
before the whole world had turned on
Elon I remember when that happened I was
like a huge Elon fan and when that story
broke I I was I was like he's got to
know something that we don't right you
gave him the benefits I was like [__] I
was like he's got to know something
maybe this guy really is a pedo
right of course he was just completely
defaming him yeah yeah
now now we know that in fact he's done
it a bunch of times now
he actually got sued for that but I
believe won the defamation lawsuit uh by
claiming that pedo was just a common uh
slaying insult in South Africa and that
he didn't actually mean
out of court
that is what this article says it says
that um that's such Mr musk told the
court this week that the phrase pedo guy
was common in South Africa where he grew
up but that doesn't make sense because
the insult is specifically about him
living right no it's nonsense but uh
apparently that that's how he was able
to default well I know it's not easy to
win defamation lawsuits against public
figures although you know a thing or two
he's not a public figure the guy he
called a pedo he's not it says speaking
to reporters outside the courtroom
afterward musk said my faith in humanity
is restored
and now he lost it once again all on
Twitter by the way
faith in humanity restored
um
that verdict surprises me unless they
were able to prove that this guy's a
public figure that makes sense but
I don't know if he passes the sniff
check on that
[Music]
second bed in a drill down people
we're going all out all right thanks for
watching everybody I'm gonna wrap this
up before it goes off the rails
okay so then there was an update
uh Elon Musk of course probably got
several calls from lawyers
friends accountants
uh that he is actually a total totally
[__] this up
they're like he probably got a call from
a lawyer that's like okay just so you
know if we fire him we owe him 50
million dollars immediately right
oh that's before the lawsuit
yeah elon's like oh I'm so sorry oh
Daniel
uh tax on to this thread he says as
someone who has worked directly with him
during a turnaround this is super
disappointing to see not only is his
work ethic Next Level his talent and
humility are world class exactly the
kind of person you want on your team
when the odds are stacked I feel certain
there's a deep misunderstanding
somewhere in here of didn't know actual
work that is insanely respectful and uh
giving Elon the benefit of the doubt
right
Elon of course responds and says based
on your comment I just did a voice call
with Hallie to figure out what's the
real verse what I was told it's a long
story better to talk to people than
communicate via tweet um
you're the CEO of Twitter saying yeah
tweets are bad actually it's a little
late bro and honestly how old are you
and your St your station in life yeah
it's really kind of late in the game for
you to realize that
Elon Musk age how old is that guy 51.
yeah
you know
he continues Elon continues I would like
to apologize to Hallie of course this
isn't a straight tweet this is in a
thread the bottom of a thread I'd like
to apologize to Ali for my
misunderstanding of the situation I
thought we could fire you but apparently
that's a horrible idea financially
no he says it was based on things I was
told that were untrue or in some cases
true but not meaningful what does that
mean you dip [__] [__] loser
it's such a [__] apology meaningful
he's still considering uh remaining at
Twitter yeah I'm sure he's super excited
to stay on Twitter Elon
I mean oh yeah yeah
I really hate him
yeah he sucks but it was fun to see uh
somebody like that get won over on him
so publicly and um
yeah and like you said I mean people
that genuinely are the types that are
always in his replies sucking his dick
about everything even they were like ah
dude like oh yeah the reply guys turned
on yeah that's how you know it was bad
it's really disappointing to see I mean
as a as a person with employees
I genuinely say I say this you have to
be a real [__] psychopath to talk to
someone like that who who you employ
Stephanie says Ethan you can't get over
how great you're looking
thank you so much
[Applause]
yeah I do think this shirt is very
flattering so I like that
thank you stack time says I work with
people in Twitter HR and holy Flocka is
it bad
oh interesting
Alex kiss
his cat says Lena the hair
they love your hair
thank you did you do it you got your
hair done
what is it did you get your hair done or
I remember you got your hair done
adjusted it for me the same time she did
ABS okay
wonderful
beautiful looks extra beautiful on
National Women's day
I was looking down at a paper thank you
guys yeah I was looking down at a paper
and I'm like ah so thank you
hey oh Ashley says I got fired for my
depression a year ago and they refused
to pay for my unemployment I was
continuously bullied there and got PTSD
I would talk to a lawyer about that one
actually
for sure
let's go that's very very sad to hear
used to pay for your unemployment I mean
that's they can so yeah if assuming
they're in the United States we should
say because I'm sure it's different in
other places but in the United States in
California if somebody files for
unemployment you can challenge it ah you
can choose to fight it and it goes to
like a mediator
huh which is really scummy obviously
yeah
um
okay
yeah talk to a lawyer God damn Tony said
love this show just suggestion whenever
the kill switch is pressed gangster
Ethan saying I got nothing to do with
this
is that possible Dan uh yeah so here's
the thing is the way it works is my
computer has a video playing on a loop
that is being sent into the machine and
when the Breton button is pressed all
it's really doing is switching over to
that other feed instead of the primary
feed and so like you were saying before
like you can't really have it do
something on demand like
like be queued up to a certain spot
because the video is always running so
it kind of has to be something that can
just be looped which is why it's the
whole card with just the generic you
know music I think right now we should
make a bunch of them and then just have
it like scroll through yeah it could
just be one long video with a bunch of
like funny I like that and then it's
just always playing and you know it's
kind of you get what you get when you
hit the button I like that I like that
um
Lena what's what's the ET on the Boba as
a curiosity
thank you Bianca for the Dono I love you
what's that
latest arrival by 4 30.
4 30.
sooner though because it's close yeah
what's the window what's the quoted
really quick yeah
it could be traffic though what's the
quoted window
but quoted wide it says latest at does
it tell you between times oh no oh
estimated is 410 actually 410 mm-hmm
I can do 410.
so up next I would like to do loves big
Subway Surfer Tick Tock analysis very
excited this has been a long time in the
works I'm gonna go to the bathroom I'm
gonna go pee go see if I can flush my
[__] down okay and um I'll be right back
sounds good sounds good
somebody just asked me do you have to
hit both buttons red and yellow so
you don't have to hit both uh one is for
video and one is for audio so the audio
one will technically just replace the
existing audio tracks with the one from
the auxiliary video that I was just
explaining and then the other one will
do the video so when you press both it
does both audio and video which in our
case what we're using it for is
advisable
um you know most people who use these
buttons uh most people most shows
are much shorter relative delay and the
reaction time is just a second or two
that's being done because the idea is
that it's in case somebody drops like an
F-bomb on national TV where they can get
fined for it [__] that see if we can do
whatever the [__] we want here on
YouTube baby
body mouth time that's right so
um
but Ethan wanted to be extra safe so he
asked me to set it to be just like when
you hit the button it just erases like
well in our case the last 20 seconds uh
in time
let's just make sure that nothing went
out so delete so it's like the Janet
Jackson super bowl situation did they
not have a button or they didn't oh they
had a button somebody missed it because
if you recall that whole incident
um and you know that was such a famous
incident that probably is with her boob
coming out this has probably been
investigated I have to imagine
um but if you remember in the video is
like it was kind of subtle and quick
yeah like you could honestly miss it she
had like a thing on her nipple too yeah
and she so people think it was like a
publicity stun oh it definitely was I
mean it was that the part of the song
where he said I'm gonna have you naked
by the end of the song I think they said
it later on they actually admitted it if
I'm not oh really I could be wrong they
admitted they did it on purpose well I
remember there was some kind of talk but
I think they were they try to say it was
like some sort of dysfunction but let me
see
um yeah
but yeah so how many somebody definitely
they missed the mark on that one I'm
with you and though I'm happy that Ethan
was so enthused and ready to hit the
button when he saw the I agree chat I
agree I like you guys didn't see it but
he slammed it immediately he was like
what the button okay
it's fun you know it's fun to hit a
button yeah especially it's comically
big it is yeah they're like cartoon
buttons yeah yeah like you know I feel
like it was small you know it's you know
it's still necessary but you know it's
just so big it's
better than one big button two you know
what's better than that Zach Lowe is
live with the Rocks you May 13th I'll be
there
you go
last show in La I cannot stress this
enough it is my last name he's not
coming back people right farewell tour
the farewell Los Angeles tour if you
want tickets just Google Zach Lewis life
of the Roxy we'll see you there I just
see Ethan has left the bathroom I wonder
if he's unclogged the toilet
nope nope no progress apparently we
still got dookie in the in the can
dookie in the can baby
he says he usually flushes it at the end
of the show that's the ceremony now
he's trying he said he tried but science
says wait till the end of the show
yep uh Jeter Jeter is a member for 13
months and sent a message and said I am
a fan
hell yeah okay
Peter wow
so just to update on nipplegate uh
there's a lot of conspiracies back and
forth but it was never confirmed by the
two performers but there are a lot of
other people involved that basically
indicate it was staged but not them
themselves
what do you think AB you're the yeah
thank you I think Janet Jackson got a
lot of undeserving heat for it and
Justin just got away I remember we
talked about that especially on
International women's day it's important
to point that out so yeah with her boob
coming out I agree with that take
JT is a menace says somebody so true
so true I'm eating Beach Bar
[Music]
how is it
I mean it's fine good sitting and
stopping around did you mess up our
display
hmm I think I might have yeah sure why
why are you going back to Jimmy he's
already sent his regards to he tried to
take you out it was there I wanted a
little bite of something sweet this is
this is how he's gonna get you I haven't
eaten anything today and that I got to
tell you that hit the spot for me
it is too sweet you know but
I don't like that it doesn't say how
much Coco's in it chocolate mocha you
know colored cream yeah they're all
different flavors
I like to know
what I'm getting myself into Coco wise
oh you should show off your new tattoos
cam your fingertips
here's my thingies
so Hindi check
fungus that does her fingers not as bad
as I was expecting them to hurt but yeah
I mean it hurt but like wasn't the worst
pain in my life
what was the worst pain in your life
waking up every morning oh
really is like gang affiliated
Affiliated in Italy I saw a comment on a
Reddit I'm sorry I'm not a mobster
don't go to Italy Italy anytime soon
stay at three dots I guess stay at a
camera see you on the streets
you come to me you tell me my tattoos
are gang affiliated
this way I did not do on purpose why
hold on I love you don't say it don't
don't say it Olivia don't say it yeah I
can't fired yeah wait what nothing
nothing that's a good impression right
I thought he did a pretty great job yeah
I did too and I don't know why you're
doing that to me bro
there's a new boss boss in town Cameron
you come here I take you in like my own
child
bring you into the family and give you a
place to work
you're of the old world you're too
Italian this is a new world we're in
America now
you gotta you gotta let me take the
reins a little bit I'm not as fast as my
feet as you man but you you win this
round no Cameron you're not listening
you come here
and you do an impression of me The
Godfather
disrespectful this is like the rally La
huh damn
ah yeah and let me say furthermore
Cameron
that your impression is quite good and
it makes me uncomfortable to see so
please have some respect
look what they did to my boy
massacred my boy
you got the face is
the Nero though when when are you saying
you mastered my boy he does this like
crying face
they massacred my boy he puts his hand
on his chin like the massacre my boy
yeah my boss Sunny Santiago was a good
boy bada bing bada boom
spaghetti
[Music]
they Massacre
he was a good boy been drinking a lot of
wine Michael it's good for you pop can
we do pop wrote more Bob dinero though I
like Bobby and your Bobby De Niro all
right let's move on let's move all right
I'm running out of time here I don't got
all day here okay there's only time
enough for one God other father
impression and you're it you're the
champ you're the champion yeah
everybody's doing a Godfather impression
We're not gonna ever get through this
show can you do your De Niro face one
time it makes me happy to see you do it
me yeah yeah yeah
there we go
saying I'm a wise guy thank you I know
that's Joe Pesci but
do I make you funny
I don't know nothing about nobody you
understand me
thank you
all right
all right love I'm gonna throw it to you
let's take a look at Subway Surfer data
on tick tock I've been in the lab I've
been I've been experimenting I've been
testing different concepts and you know
seeing different flavors different
flavors all kinds of all different kinds
and I think I'm I think we've finally
cracked the cracked the code here
oh yeah
yeah
so do you want me to open the stuff or
you want to do it yeah
okay so let's take a look here tell me
first describe to me your scientific
process
so it started off the normal regular
meme like the the kind of Subway Surfer
right then we it evolved to soap cutting
and then kinetic sand and then uh we had
a brilliant idea of using both at the
same time and we've just gone down the
neem hole kind of that way but what was
your process in comparing right the ADHD
one versus the normal one yeah so we try
to like just posting a normal one
without the ADHD stuff and one with the
one with half half right or you have the
interesting we've done a like a
comparison test so you posted one for
one yes one with one without exactly
which one did you post first
um just random I posted them right after
each other and I tried to randomize yeah
just all right so I've opened the uh
stats here what are we looking at
all right so this is February that's
right around where I started doing these
Sumer ads or Sumer edits and as you can
see the views are up 136 percent right I
know and this gets even crazier mind you
we were banned during February right
[Music]
yeah but still so we were this is three
weeks and we still outperformed the
previous week by 136 it's pretty crazy
so it definitely works
but how does it compare if you're
looking at like month by month the whole
year I wonder how it compares to other
months we average uh like 12 million a
month we're moving big numbers here
major numbers yeah
okay so so we posted two today both are
performing better with the Zoomer edit
versus without let's take a look yeah
these are two just random ones like they
didn't go Mega viral but it's clear that
it's working
this is the same video
uh no the that one and the one and it
was the right one
there you go yeah this one and this one
yeah okay yeah I mean it's it's not that
one is not mind-blowing so show me a
good one
well uh if you open the the the
slideshow the slideshow okay let's take
a look at the slideshow yeah
so Zoomer brain is the presentation yes
let's go ahead and start this dirty dude
Zoomer Tick Tock attention span our
analysis and evolution here we go Subway
Surfer
Love's been in the attention span Labs
testing video engagement both with and
without side content doing company
podcast clips of 13 Clips tested with
and without majority of the clips with
zoomerbrain did better that's right so
was it a hundred percent but the
majority did do better right so I kind
of came to con to the conclusion that
there's certain clips that need the
super brain and certain Clips don't need
it for example when one thing that that
I've been struggling with uh previously
is that for example when you're talking
about politics and stuff like that with
Hassan it's been a bit hard to keep
attention through that especially
politics clip they they Excel with the
Sumer brain okay that's interesting
here's an outstanding examples Jeff
whitock eye surgery
so I'm curious okay so here you go you
say with the Zoomer edit 1.3 million
without Zoomer edit 80 000. yeah that's
a master now which one was posted first
though because I do feel that's relevant
here
um I don't know in that case I'm sure we
could find I think it was the Zoomer one
okay Zoomer one first yeah but I've seen
them posted in reverse order too where
it's still well here's the Rebecca Black
one with Zoomer vid 2.5 million without
Zoomer vid 1.2 that's interesting that
they both did well right yeah
that was just a banger of a clip I guess
again I do wonder which one was posted
first I'm gonna try to find out and then
we move on to esteemy's uh clip with
Zoomer vid 250 views without Zoomer 50
000.
yeah these are three outstanding
examples the Rebecca One Rebecca one was
posted right after each other the Sumer
first like one second before and the
other one right after okay so right
practically right at the same time I do
think Tick Tock probably favors their
earlier one but I don't know that's a
theory
yeah
maybe but I I'm certain that it does
help I'm just by looking at the general
picture it's consistently higher on the
on the Zoomer ones even if you're
reversing the posting order let's take a
look the end of our Nationwide Adderall
shortage is nowhere in sight we've sent
our top scientists back into the
attention span labs to craft the
Ultimate Super Brain Tick Tock
scientifically proven to go mega mega
mega viral that's right click here to
view okay
okay so this is uh so this is Zoomer
brain azuba edit that a fantastic create
um with bonus enhancements okay so this
is for you Zoomers who are waiting on
your ADHD medicine and I will say I
haven't shown this to any of the Zoomer
staff on on our site so we could do some
test objects live right now all right
Olivia and Zach neither of you have seen
it right
now Feast your eyes Zoomers all right
let's take a look you know
I feel like that's more powerful
all right give me a second and people
can go watch it on Tick Tock along with
us
um and a powerful moment of solidarity
give me two seconds a stunning moment of
solidarity
why don't you go to the Tick Tock page
so you can be ready to watch it I am
okay
fascinating stunning display
I think you might have to watch it on
the on there for now okay so let's just
watch it all right uh never mind
let's go back to the PowerPoint
and a stunning display of
solidarity
all right here it is two you know I
actually did something yesterday I met
my friend at Topgolf it's like a massive
three-story driving right you can eat
and drink there they serve you yeah but
then they've got this crazy Tech where
they can track the ball
it's really crazy it's like super
futuristic there it's [__] dangerous
there people are drinking hitting balls
all crazy you know sometimes I was like
it goes like parallel to you somehow
you're hitting it out but it goes
totally sideways right and the people
around there like nobody there really
knows how to golf
[Music]
there's dudes who are just like they're
hitting it like it's all on the line
I'm getting hard bro like these guys
think that they will never get laid
again if they don't hit that ball
probably
and they're right they're right about
that
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
I I genuinely think that's a good clip
for tick tock it's very good
so basically you guys scientifically
crafted this for the highest success
position yeah every sound bite
everything
did everything
um and every songbot has proven to be a
Super Brain you know I actually I really
like the way that you framed it where
it's like the cups on top I always
thought the video should be in the
middle
um yeah
[Music]
it's crazy it's actually I thought it
was super entertaining to be honest I
think fantastic and also informative I
feel like I learned a lot I listened to
everything I said no it's like super do
you think we should do this on like
politicial like politics too that'd be
[__] hilarious yeah like sensitive
topics and and stuff like that are you
guys actually down to create these kind
of videos regularly how much work was
that well
um I'm down to do like one a week I will
say it was driving me crazy to listen to
those [__] sound bites yeah in repeat
like cam was like in the in the lab
cooking for a while and he showed it to
me and I hadn't seen it and I was like
cracking up it was just like so stupid
and I look over at Cam and he's just
like
he's hating it like he's [__] hating
life which I understand and if you ever
edit anything you watch the same thing
10 000 times you can mute the track
though when you're editing no you got to
hit the sound bites the right right at
the right right moment yeah well here it
is uh wait no this isn't up what is this
is like an honorable mention
yeah
so this is you talking about
um
there was no intermission dude it was
one isn't it
these are the things I I'm trying like
different things very very cool I think
I actually think you guys should make
one of those a week it's [__] awesome
all right and I we chose a very boring
topic which is Golf and no but the top
golf was great I loved that it was so
interesting to me let's see how it does
I'm genuinely curious all right
um in fact I want you guys to help us
make it go viral where is it being held
for reviewers it's being re-rendered it
was a the aspect there was an aspect
ratio oh you guys haven't uploaded it
yet yeah he's gonna throw it up in a
minute I see he's our he's rendering a
fix right now all right let me know
where that happens
[__] that Benadryl's kicking in huh
that's why I'm so tired yeah I forgot
[__]
well we're uh almost at three hours so
um well I'm waiting for my Boba dig
my eyes are so puffy
for the third one no
definitely not
crush it up and snort it
do people snort Benadryl they'll be the
first yeah no one does it like us
true nobody's snorting Benadryl live
so I'm just gonna talk to the uh Boba
gets here because I'm gonna be here
anyway
okay we love that
oh I like this guy Joe is hungry he's
kind of everything to me
this guy Joe is hungry he makes a food
focused Tick Tock account where he does
food reviews but there's something
interesting about Joe other than the
fact that he's hungry
he is
an absolutely Superstar
editor with Supernatural editing skills
he takes these food to the next [__]
level
he only has 22 000 followers always on
YouTube as well
um here's one that kind of popped off
recently to Wingstop Chicken Sandwich
review but this man deserves to go more
time for the Joe is hungry this one only
got 400 000 views and you guys are going
to see what I'm talking about Joe is
hungry you guys what you put it back
together
look like this is what it actually looks
like and this is what it's supposed to
look like
it's not that far off
um I didn't see the flex of uh herbs and
spices on it
say what oh yeah no it's not perfect but
you know I mean that's a big deal
this man is really good at editing and
he's got this slick style that I just I
love it here's what his newest one about
Chipotle steak or something it's time
for the Joe is hungry big reveal
spin that Joe
spin it like a tabletop
this party's just getting started it's a
joke
yes yes
what the hell is this Chipotle has like
a new steak quesadilla dude I just want
to say separately
Chipotle has the [__] worst
quesadillas dude it's like a joke what
they put out there is
it's they got a lot of I don't ride for
them anymore like I used to hell no
dude I remember when Chipotle first came
out I was in like high school I think
and that [__] blew my mind I was like
this is fast food this is insane yeah it
was uh it was decent things have changed
man yeah
two what's up you know everybody please
go show your support is important wait
is this scientific if you're actually
encouraging our fans to it's not
scientific we're scientists go do it no
it's not it's not perfectly scientific
Dan but it's not gonna pop off unless
it's a good vid science is gay like we
can give it a we can give it a boost but
we can't make it go viral okay actually
did something yesterday I met my friend
at Top Golf it's like a massive shit's
so [__] driving range you can eat and
drink there they serve you yeah but then
they've got this one
so now it's time for the Joe is hungry
big reveal
spin it spin me right right baby right
rum damn that's claimed music bro or is
this on the list I don't know no these
should all be good I think he was using
because they're from his YouTube videos
well you you linked this one or wait
where did I get oh no I clicked over to
this one okay then it might be yeah yeah
let's let's find something I'll just
watch the ones that are on the list then
there you go
genius
chicken sandwich wrap KFC oh yeah I feel
that Benadryl now just came at me
this one we can have audio
yes dude if he hooked up with review bra
they'd be unstoppable because review bro
he's got the delivery down but the
editing is is wanting that looks
disgusting what the [__] that's is that
even chicken it looks like cheese
there's no texture
there's no texture whoa that looks like
a store-bought tortilla too it's the
inside of a rock that tortilla looks
[__] awful man what is the uh what is
this like what is the uh this is KFC's
new chicken wrap KFC
that wrap they're not gonna toast it or
grill it oh God I'm trying to get a
pause on that
there we go
I don't know about that one KFC
hey that's the saddest meal really
that's like what you make at home when
you're just like [__] bit [__]
everything well it's like you have a
chicken and a plain tortilla and called
it it's like that old H3 video you made
with the the college dude he teaches
kids how to cook in college
microwaving for one yeah yeah exactly
sure what why would you buy this it's
just
this is sad food this is sad sad food
[Music]
so it doesn't really reveal it does he
he just kind of shows it off
in the uh his YouTube videos he uh
reviews it I see yeah it looks like this
is just the clickbait really can I give
you some advice hungry Joe if you see
this I think for your tick tocks to
really pop off you need to have your
opinion in there as well the edits are
awesome but I'm there for the opinion I
want the whole you know give me the
whole summary Joe three oh oh three yeah
three oh yeah also he's using most of
his own sounds if he would have used
Tick Tock sounds it would help too there
it is but then we can watch it right so
God bless him here's the one about the
um now it's time to move on Duncan's new
bacon avocado tomato sandwich mm-hmm
two the Joe is hungry big reveal so is
this guy actually in a kitchen or does
he just love all this stuff I think this
is like his home studio setup because I
see lots of Macy's Pizza stuff no I
think maybe he owns a pizza place but
then it's like a manager's office it
looks like little Seasons multiple so
maybe he's just designed it to look that
way
this man loves fast food I love that
firm so it reminds me of Casey neistat's
Studio shot but with pizza instead of
beer
it's awesome
this is my fave wait go back he looks
down at it it's an empty the box is
closed brother
three this part big reveal
what was that shot
this guy is pretty much case a nice type
of fast food it's yeah it's part of the
dance dude he's dancing yeah well I
thought he was like trying to look at it
I was like look he's like doing he's
looking
it's doing everything in rhythm
I get that
just saying it can't see through cards
Style
yeah there's style points right here
it's a Vibe right now for sure
[Music]
dude what that's just like a sandwich
I mean that's like the most at home
looking sandwich I've ever seen
[Music]
that looks really avocado is so Brown
yeah I prefer yeah
with this kind of food you don't want to
look too closely yeah yeah I prefer my
avocado unseen
if it yeah you know unless it's fresh I
don't want to see it
so true
and this is what it's supposed to look
like this is what it looks like and this
is what I think they did a pretty
faithful
uh advertising
I can't get enough of Joe he is hungry
man
so am I
Sonic's new steak and bacon grilled
cheese reveal hold on to your seeds guys
average amount do the math and you come
up with a
let's see 89
. so he's including some of them info in
this one
somebody's experimenting with the format
you know what did he say is upscale
incense an ounce five bucks for five and
a half to six
upscale
five to six bucks for a sandwich that's
a little upscale for Joe
have some have some I mean in this new
age that doesn't seem too far off like
yo you deserve good things man don't
yeah you're so far yeah that's true
treat yourself
you know
McDonald's is on the upscale side a
little too fancy for Old Joe yeah
I guess if the whole range is just the
fast food restaurants maybe you know
little case has been having a rough day
at work Camp say what company I work for
but can I get a huge [__] you for my
boss his name is Mickey Mouse Papa bless
oh I see what I think I know what you're
saying [__] you [__] you [__] you [__]
you Mickey Mouse
you [__] [__] you [__] you [__] you [__]
you [__] yeah what he said
we're with you little okay [__] you so
hopefully they'll pull this one out of
the weeds when we do the Joe's hungry
bite test which leads us on to the next
test the Joe is hungry big reveal
what go
break it down for me Joey oh oh I like
how he folds he's so delicate with the
wrapping oh he threw it
don't need that
I don't know is this some kind of
movement in fast food to make like at
home looking ass sandwiches
no it's just I mean you know they never
look like they do in the commercial no
but like it's the bread or something it
looks like a sandwich your mom made at
home like I just that's not what I'm
looking for in fast food just the slices
and [__] right
that looks [__] what is that
did you eat that
no when you look at it it's just you
don't want it
this is the oh it's steak
I need that I think it looks good okay
thank you
I would eat the [__] out of that I
probably would to be totally yeah no I I
wouldn't ask questions
there's so much white bread this is
this it actually looks like and this is
what it's supposed to look like this is
I'm not sure I want this sandwich it's
like a little [__] weird
it's all hanging out
the mustard and mayonnaise is just like
there's too much of it hanging out
on his YouTube he includes a ton of
details like calorie intake uh price per
Sandwich price for the combo give me his
most uh viewed one it's in the dock
let's look at his his crowning
achievement Here YouTube channel here it
is BLT Quarter Pounder cheat with cheese
okay
this is McDonald's the one and only
the king of fast food
full 60 frames
high def
[Music]
wait what Nathan said Mickey Mouse
entered public domain oh next year oh
wait for that Disney Dizzy's about to be
hating my ass
little kids Pinocchio
oh that's crazy I've been here about
that for years is it actually
yeah actually happening the steam early
early Disney creation will sue me public
property so like the Steamboat Willie uh
that's such that's so awesome and Disney
is scared that people who will like ruin
the Mickey Mouse image so they're
actually changing their main mascot
people have been saying oh they wrote
people will ruin this so they're
switching it to that Dragon whatever his
name is wait they can't change the mouse
they're gonna get rid of Mickey Mouse is
there a dragon what dragon
yeah huh
from Mickey Mouse decades because
they're yeah I mean 100 Years of
branding
because they're pissed at what happened
with uh what's his name the bear Pooh
bear or what's it yeah we made Winnie
the Pooh [__] yeah there you go
they don't like that well of course they
don't
I love it though
I can't wait to put that on a shirt oh
yeah all right so here is Joe is hungry
reviewing McDonald's new Smokey BLT
quarter pounder with cheese okay let's
get into it guys
see this okay this editing's throwing me
off of it
okay now this this people like oh
is he gonna eat the cat oh no Joe's
hungry Joe's gonna eat that cat yeah you
never know what's gonna happen with Joe
when he gets hungry
right here is
[Music]
the color 87 keep the dirty side down
Tara Lynn you are the real deal last but
not least Sloppy Joe's sends a special
birthday shout out to my favorite
subscriber Alex
the plan today is to check out a new
fast food menu item which brings us to
the local McDonald's to check out their
limited time offer the new Smokey BLT
quarter pounder with cheese according to
McDonald's this thing is supposed to be
cooked when you place the order so it is
technically cooked to order I'm a little
bit skeptical about this claim because
McDonald's is a true industry leader in
not cooking to order and we won't know
any of that for sure dude Joe's his
[__] meter is going off yeah he
knows and I I had the same thought when
I heard that Joe I was like that's
there's no way those are made to order
so he's on his [__] this man knows what
he's talking about
I think I hear bags of boba
do I hear Boba bags
bags of boba in the area
10 minutes and it's uh been 10 minutes
so um probably
bubble bag bubble bag
no backup you wanted us to choose Ethan
is hungry
yes you guys thank you
your double shot of espresso I'm
wondering because it looked milk
doesn't look oh yeah
I love the top you can just shake it
it's kind of like the toilet plunger
um
kind of that's really true
so you're supposed to shake it up right
uh uh it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter and you know Boba is the last
great straw
Haven
yeah you cannot find normal straws in
California at least it's hard yet Boba
says no we will give you the biggest
[__] plastic straw you've ever sucked
out of in your life well you need it I
mean you need it yeah
slick
all right hell yeah oh
good the flavor is unexpected all
different flavors
who did anyone else get the green
so
chocolate mocha you know Common cream
yeah they're all different flavors I
just got coffee Bubba
it tastes like honeydew melon in the
best way
excellent mmm
it's a lot of boba
have you got extra bubbles
that's why we yeah just chill on the
Boba now
boba time is this a popular one yeah
it's a chain they're all over the place
at least here in L.A they're all over
the place actually it's called it's boba
time that's true
it's boba time
you got the green one
I love matcha green tea
different type of green
Mamma Mia
does this have the double dirty in it
Alina it doesn't taste like it
yes tastes great I don't even notice the
double there yet Let It Go
you're gonna be Juiced dude
hmm
you see my Photoshop
nope
let me open up
the Bobby T's here
Bobby T
with little with little Bobby plushies
Eugene restaurant hey do you think and
keemstar has gotten his uh 7 000 Roblox
plushies yet
I don't know
are that did he cancel the order
um no probably not
no he like
he cornered himself into that
plushie orders and then keemstar who
doesn't even like Bobby an effort to
show that I'm the real cheap coward and
he's the hero generous King
let me talk bought like 500 plus year
dolls
he's gonna hang outside at elementary
school and oh no
yeah I don't think the kids won't even
want bubbly plushies even a child would
be like that ain't right
[Music]
everybody's saying they definitely
didn't add the espresso to your drink it
looks yeah it would look darker right I
feel like yeah
did they charge us for Atlanta
no it wasn't um well let me check the
receipt actually because
if they charge us for us we gonna have a
problem
I'm taking this to Twitter well she I
think it's like 25 cents per shot
on the chart of espresso that's really
cheap that maybe it isn't there maybe
it's just 25 cents yeah maybe they just
didn't put a lot there's you cannot do
espresso shot of spreads over 25 cents
espresso flavoring yeah
it's one of where Boba chain s yeah
even so that's super cheap I don't even
understand the mechanics of that
Ian does yours taste like can you pour a
little caffeine in it yeah mine does
mine has it too it's [__] dope did
you ask for it
yeah your guys is dirty yeah yeah
extra dirty [__] yeah dude
we have cold brew if you want to pour it
in
to get the experience
I'm loving the experience
it is boba time you guys it's boba time
so I have a question so are these like
pre-made or how do they get the top on
here they have a machine that um
he steals it on yeah oh my God it's so
good
that's a good question Zach but I love
what they do there with the top all
right it's just like you know one of
those things that makes you wonder makes
you think like an existential crisis
dude
uh Amanda
quack quack
quatch a Mandy Amanda got that stinky
quatch don't say that Jesus
button you for that Amanda thank you she
said boba time is mid
you'll need to try sun right
is that another Boba Place
I've never heard of it I don't know if
that's another chain or what I know boba
time isn't the uh
the fanciest Boba place you can get but
um or just fancy Boba but it's around
and it's relatively cheap like what is
Frankie Boba you know what I mean what
is it
uh
uh I don't
it's not a boba snob I know these do
look nice though first time I had Bobo
was like only a couple years ago oh yeah
yeah
that's interesting Zach tell me more I
was uncultured tell me more about what
what else did you describe for the first
time two years ago oh
oh I see the variety here is interesting
menthol cigarettes okay fascinating
um you can't get those anymore in
California I know a guy oh wait a minute
I have been to this place
yeah that she suggested dude is it good
does it check out uh it is pretty good
it is pretty good that's like the creme
brulee yeah they have like yeah they
have like kind of hoity toys there's 73
or 70 I'm so [__] up on Benadryl
there's
37 000 people watching this right now
yeah maybe we should wrap it up
yo show my name I should definitely
let's wrap it up should my next field
recording be in a [__] boba time ooh
what's the angle yeah everyone's like oh
I'm like hey what's what's the angle
why are you going to boba time like
what's the what's the to do another
thing field recording for a segment of
drinking Boba oh
somehow audio recording yeah oh
boba time yeah what did you think I said
I didn't I thought you wanted to go
there and film a bit no no no
just record with a mic
that I like what kind that I like
Zach you should tell the story about the
menthols if you're comfortable talking
about a crime you're committing oh yeah
so um
including the state of California you
can't buy a flavored tobacco Vapes
anything any different flavors all
different flavors so um there was a
smoke shop I wanted to do and I'm like
hey they can't sell these anymore
um but I was wondering if you might have
any left over
um he's like uh
he's like
come with me
and he pulls out a key and takes me in a
back room and there's all these like
menthol cigarettes and Vapes hell yeah
El Dorado dude
I found it interesting he didn't even up
charge you for the Contraband nah normal
price I had to pay him cash though is
that way back to Glendale recently no
this is a different spot
I know a place like that in Glendale
what else was back there other than just
like all all different flavors of Vapes
and uh
you know you can't buy those anymore
which I think personally I think is
[__] but whatever
the flavored Vapes I get the Menthol has
been around forever right I don't think
kids are going out of their way to smoke
Menthol right it's also I'm not gonna
say that
let me type it oh let the kids smoke
dude what the [__]
yeah
my thought exactly low give the babies
gummy bear a little nicotine Babas did
you prove that or no
uh no that's definitely something people
have pointed out
um yeah menthols are disproportionately
Smoked by uh
my black people I said is we didn't ban
right and ban normal cigarettes we
banned you know uh Newports and stuff
which is pretty shitty and cools man I
[__] love cools yeah I mean listen
like I get it cigarettes are terrible
it's a huge impact on public health and
everything but yeah just spanning the
menthols without Banning
regular cigarettes is kind of whack
kind of whack
it is working though since they started
taxing it like crazy it's the smoking
rate has gone down significantly I don't
know if that's a cultural thing or it's
because people are like [__] I'm not
paying 25 for it back
I think it's both I mean yeah
it's it's been I mean it's been just a
steady decline for decades now right so
by the way yeah a Nook finally
acknowledged us
we uploaded the full edit he said thank
you for choosing my voice the video
looks so fun
I believe
we've been persistent did we message him
from this uh tiktok account you can't
message someone on Tick Tock unless you
both follow
playing hard to get with us going
through the spider Silver Screen and
only says it's gonna happen
and dance again
how do we get him
I'll do anything
I'll climb any mountain
across any River
I will get paid any amount of money
I need to speak to a Nook
no enough
I need you you have a Nook in my heart
wow that's good thank you nice
all right we should go we should go
it's probably time though yeah I've
we've got a I gotta plan uh leftovers
and everything tonight I wanna get going
on that the comeback app okay come back
it is going to be a big app there's so
much went down yeah so on tomorrow
morning we'll be back with leftovers
Friday we'll have a nice fun after dark
and Monday There's no show remember
but I will say that um
I forgot
okay I forgot I was gonna say fantastic
should we button that no no
um
oh I love that
[Laughter]
good night Moon all that Benadryl you
know yeah the cow jumping over the moon
good night Mouse good night clock good
night comb
good night porridge good night lamp
good night Three Bears
sitting in chairs
good night good night
[Music]
foreign